Rana Awdish is a doctor in the intensive care unit at a big hospital, Henry Ford in Detroit. And when corona cases started arriving in March, she made up this job for herself.
Rana Awdish是底特律亨利福特医院重症监护室的一名医生。三月份新冠病例开始涌入时，她为自己安排了这项工作。
How are you?
你好吗？
I'm good.
我很好。
She started spending hours of each day walking the fourth, fifth, and sixth floors that made up the ICU, just checking in on her co-workers, seeing how they were doing. Which means that maybe more than any single person in the hospital, she knows best what the staff has been going through at every stage of this pandemic. And she tries to help. Even, for instance, when a unit clerk tells her that she is short on bleach and wipes.
她开始每天花几小时走遍ICU所在的四、五、六层楼，去探望她的同事，看看他们的情况。这意味着，也许比医院里的任何一个人都更清楚，在这次大流行的各个阶段，医护人员经历了什么。她试图提供帮助。比如，当一名病房文员告诉她漂白剂和湿巾不够用时。
I'll see if I can poke some people.
我去催催看。
OK, thank you.
好的，谢谢。
I love you.
我爱你。
I love you, too.
我也爱你。
Miki Meek on our staff is the person who first reached out to Rana and got to know her. Hey there, Miki.
我们的工作人员Miki Meek是第一个联系Rana并了解她的人。嘿，Miki。
Hey, Ira. So one of the things that's new about coronavirus is how much death the doctors and nurses see. It's relentless. And Rana especially worries about the doctors who are still in training, the residents and fellows.
嘿，Ira。冠状病毒带来的一个新情况是，医生和护士目睹了太多的死亡。这种感觉是持续不断的。Rana特别担心那些仍在接受培训的医生，也就是住院医生和研究员们。
Ah, right. Henry Ford is a big teaching hospital.
啊，对。亨利福特是一所大型教学医院。
Yeah, so when Rana was a resident, she says the doctors in charge never checked in with the trainees about their feelings after a patient died. She says it's traumatic. You can feel like you failed them. And Rana says that two of the residents she trained with actually died by suicide. She sometimes still wonders if someone checking in might have made a difference.
是的，所以当Rana还是住院医生时，她说负责的医生从来不会在病人去世后关心受训人员的感受。她说这是一种创伤。你会觉得是自己失职了。Rana说，她曾一起受训的两名住院医生最终自杀身亡。她有时仍会想，如果当时有人去关心一下他们，会不会有所不同。
So when she heard about the team of Henry Ford trainees who lost a patient, she made a point of stopping by to see them. They were all in this cramped, windowless workroom. It's on the fifth floor.
所以，当她听说亨利福特的一组受训人员失去了一位病人时，她特意去看了看他们。他们都挤在五楼一个没有窗户的狭小办公室里。
Hi, you guys. How are you?
嘿，你们好。你们怎么样？
How are you? I was trying to write an email to you, but I got caught up.
你好吗？我本来想给你写封邮件，但被别的事耽搁了。
That's why we came down, because I figured it was like a better talking thing than-- we heard there was a bad day.
这就是我们过来的原因，我想这比邮件更好交流——我们听说今天过得很糟糕。
There was a young 22-year-old woman who died, and everyone took it pretty bad.
有一个22岁的年轻女性去世了，大家都很伤心。
Yeah.
是的。
So--
所以——
There wasn't a dry eye.
没有一个人没掉眼泪。
Anywhere.
到处都是。
That's a resident named Rim saying there wasn't a dry eye. I'm not sure I've ever heard doctors talk like this among themselves about what it's like when a patient dies.
那位住院医生Rim说没有一个人没掉眼泪。我不太确定我是否听过医生们这样在私下里谈论病人去世时的感受。
I have to say, it's interesting. You've played me this tape, and before this conversation with the trainees even get started, their leader, Jay Lakshmikanth, heads for the door to leave. And we had to kind of blocks him.
我不得不说，这很有趣。你给我播放了这段录音，甚至在与受训人员的谈话开始之前，他们的领导Jay Lakshmikanth就往门口走去，想要离开。我们不得不拦住他。
You guys can chat. I've got to go do this thing.
你们聊吧。我得去办点事。
I'm going to walk over here.
我就站在这儿。
Yeah.
好的。
So she stands in front of the door, and she opens up this bag of donated scrub caps that have sharks and dinosaurs on them.
她站在门前，打开了一个装有捐赠的防菌帽的袋子，上面印着鲨鱼和恐龙图案。
Did it make you too sad? Is that why you just took yourself out of the conversation?
是因为太难过了吗？这就是你刚才想离开谈话的原因吗？
No, well--
不，嗯——
I feel like you need one of these, though, because I'm seeing your hair.
我觉得你还是需要一个，因为我看到你的头发了。
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
Do you know how many of those I have?
你知道我有多少这种帽子吗？
Why aren't you wearing them?
那你为什么不戴呢？
People keep giving them to me. It's sort of a hint.
人们一直在送给我。这算是一种暗示吧。
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
And then Rana, she turned to that resident, Rim, to get her to say more about her feelings about this patient who died. They'd taken care of her for a whole month.
接着Rana转向Rim医生，想让她多说说对那位过世病人的感受。他们照顾了她整整一个月。
What were you sharing about the patient?
你刚才在分享关于那位病人的什么事？
Oh, no, it was just, you know-- like, she's 22. She's just like one of us. And I was just staring at how beautiful she was.
哦，没什么，就是，你知道——她才22岁。就像我们中的一员。我只是盯着看她是多么漂亮。
Aww.
啊。
Like, her eyelashes, her nails, her toenails. She worked in the eyelash business. She was-- like, we saw her pictures. Her mom shared her pictures with us. And she was so beautiful She was the hardest case for us. I know, for me, personally, I wanted to quit many times. Many days, I would imagine the conversation with Dr. Perry. I would just tell him, I can't do it anymore.
比如她的睫毛、她的指甲、她的脚趾甲。她是做睫毛生意的。我们看过她的照片。她妈妈和我们分享了她的照片。她是真的太漂亮了。她是让我们感到最痛苦的病例。对我个人而言，我曾多次想辞职。好几天，我都在脑海里构思与Perry医生的谈话。我只想告诉他，我实在做不下去了。
Aww.
啊。
But it's almost over, so it's like--
但快结束了，所以就像是——
We all have those days. We literally all have those days. It's crazy what we expect of ourselves.
我们都有过这样的日子。我们真的都有。我们对自己有这样的要求简直太疯狂了。
I've cried on rounds multiple times. I've had to leave to take a break to cry, and then come back. It's just really hard. And I have such a good--
我曾在查房时多次哭泣。我不得不离开去休息室哭一场，然后再回来。这真的很困难。我有一个非常好的——
Jay had tried to get Rim to take a day off to get a break. The next day was her son's seventh birthday. But Rim didn't want to leave the rest of her team hanging.
Jay曾试图让Rim休一天假休息一下。第二天是她儿子的七岁生日。但Rim不想把剩下的团队丢下不管。
And he said--
他说——
Your son's birthday, come on.
你儿子的生日，拜托。
Yeah, I know. It's OK.
是的，我知道。没关系。
And you miss it.
你会错过的。
Come, finish my work, and then I'll go.
来，帮我做完工作，我就走。
No.
不。
No, it's OK. He doesn't wake up till 11:00 anyways. [LAUGHS]
不，没事的。他反正不到11点是不会醒的。[笑]
You know what seven is?
你知道七岁意味着什么吗？
I got him a drone. I got him many toys, so--
我给他买了一架无人机。我给他买了很多玩具，所以——
Toys aren't going to replace you. Do you know what seven is? It's a lucky number in Hinduism.
玩具代替不了你。你知道七岁意味着什么吗？在印度教里，这是一个幸运数字。
Yeah?
是吗？
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
In my culture, it's a very lucky number.
在我的文化里，这是一个非常幸运的数字。
Even here, with white people.
即便是对这里的人来说，也是一样。
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
Hey, have you seen this room? We don't know about white people.
嘿，你们见过这个房间了吗？我们对其他人了解不多。
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
We chose Henry Ford Hospital because it's in Detroit. The city is 80% Black. Black Americans have been dying of COVID-19 at higher rates than anybody else. In Michigan, they are four times more likely to die than whites. Henry Ford usually gets a mix of Black and white patients from all over the Midwest. But with the pandemic, the hospital basically turned into a huge COVID ward for the city of Detroit, and the patients in the ICU were now mostly Black. The staff says the majority were essential workers-- bus drivers, police officers, firefighters, sanitation workers, people from grocery stores.
我们选择亨利福特医院是因为它位于底特律。这座城市80%是黑人。美国黑人死于COVID-19的比率比任何人都高。在密歇根州，他们死于新冠的可能性是白人的四倍。亨利福特医院通常接收来自中西部各地的黑人和白人病人。但随着疫情爆发，这家医院基本上变成了底特律市的一个巨大新冠病房，而ICU里的病人现在大多数是黑人。医护人员说，绝大多数是必要岗位的工作人员——公交车司机、警察、消防员、环卫工人、超市员工。
It's personal on a lot of levels.
在很多层面上，这都很私人。
Dr. Geneva Tatem is one of the few Black doctors in the ICU and one of the senior doctors in the hospital. She's a pulmonologist. Her family moved to Detroit when she was 10. She has deep ties to the city now, and a deep awareness of what the virus has done to Black people there.
Geneva Tatem医生是ICU里为数不多的黑人医生之一，也是医院的资深医生之一。她是一位肺科专家。她10岁时全家搬到了底特律。她现在与这座城市有着深厚的联系，并深刻意识到病毒给那里的黑人造成了怎样的伤害。
I mean, I've had friends' parents, I've had multiple church members, multiple community leaders die. When I walk into the ICU and 15 out of 16 patients is a Black male between the age of 45 and 75, it's really an emotional, emotional thing.
我是说，我朋友的父母、教会的成员、社区的领袖，很多人都去世了。当我走进ICU，发现16个病人中有15个是45到75岁之间的黑人男性，这真的是一件非常令人感伤的事情。
Dr. Tatum lives alone, but because of the stress of COVID, she's talking to a therapist for the first time-- her cousin.
Tatem医生独居，但由于新冠带来的压力，她第一次开始看心理医生——她的表亲。
She has way more phone calls with me than she would probably care to admit. I probably owe her thousands of dollars in counseling money [LAUGHS] at this point.
她和我打的电话比她愿意承认的要多得多。到了这一步，我欠她的心理咨询费大概有几千美元了。[笑]
We started recording the staff at this hospital in mid-April, because we wanted to see what it is like for them to be going for so long in this intense and difficult situation. Rana started recording these conversations on her iPhone for us, with everybody's permission and knowledge. And she sent out emails to 40 people, urging them to talk to us, and to be honest about what's really happening in the hospital and tell everything, including, quote, "where we fail at times." "Be you," she wrote. "I love you."
我们从四月中旬开始记录这家医院的员工情况，因为我们想看看他们在这种紧张而困难的情况下坚持了这么久是什么感觉。Rana征得所有人的同意，用她的iPhone为我们记录了这些对话。她给40个人发了邮件，鼓励他们与我们交谈，诚实地说出医院里真正发生的事情，告知一切，包括她所说的“我们有时失败的地方”。“做你自己，”她写道，“我爱你。”
The day in mid-April that we started talking to Rana and the doctors at Henry Ford was the very first day that the number of people admitted to the ER was fewer than the day before. It was the very first day after their peak, and the number of COVID patients has slowly dropped since then. We wanted to follow a hospital staff over time, because we wanted to see how they managed, and adapted, and adjusted, and just what it did to them personally.
四月中旬我们开始与Rana和亨利福特的医生们交谈的那天，是急诊科入院人数首次低于前一天的一天。那是他们达到顶峰后的第一天，此后新冠病人的数量一直在缓慢下降。我们想长期跟踪报道一支医院团队，因为我们想看看他们如何应对、适应和调整，以及这些对他们个人造成了什么影响。
And so we did regular calls with nurses and doctors on the Henry Ford staff for 2 and 1/2 months. And what we're going to bring you this hour are the moments that just really struck us and surprised us, of all sorts. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Stay with us.
所以，我们在两个半月里定期与亨利福特医院的护士和医生通话。在这个节目中，我们将带给你那些真正打动我们、让我们感到惊讶的瞬间。来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》。请继续收听。
Robyn Semien is the producer on our staff who talked to Dr. Tatem, who you just heard. And Dr. Tatem told her this story that gives a sense of the situation at Henry Ford and in Detroit. Robyn will explain.
Robyn Semien是我们节目的制片人，她采访了刚才提到的Tatem医生。Tatem医生给她讲了一个故事，让人感受到亨利福特和底特律当时的处境。Robyn会为大家解释。
In our first interview, I asked Dr. Tatem a benign question about COVID patients using FaceTime to talk to their families who can't visit the ICU because the disease is so contagious. And as an answer, she told me a story so harrowing, it speaks to the relentlessness and devastation of the disease on the city, its speed and cruelty. It was about a patient in his early 40s--
在第一次采访中，我问了Tatem医生一个关于新冠病人通过FaceTime与无法进入ICU探视的家人交谈的问题。作为回答，她给我讲了一个非常惨痛的故事，它讲述了这种疾病在城市中的残酷性，以及它的传播速度和无情。关于一个40多岁的病人——
--who had Down syndrome, who was being cared for by his sister at home.
——他患有唐氏综合症，一直由他的姐姐在家照顾。
His sister brought him in with COVID symptoms. She was also taking care of her mother, who was also sick with COVID, so she had to drop him off at the hospital by himself.
他的姐姐带着他来看新冠症状。她当时也在照顾也感染了新冠的母亲，所以她不得不把他一个人留在医院。
We bring him in. He's very sick. We brought him into the ICU. You know, we're gowned, and masked, and face shields, and gloves, and that physical barrier between us and him. And we're trying to explain to him what in the world is going on.
我们将他送进来。他病得很重。我们将他带进了ICU。你知道，我们穿着防护服、戴着口罩、面罩和手套，我们之间存在着物理屏障。我们试图向他解释到底发生了什么。
He doesn't understand it. He just sees a bunch of people dressed this way and is scared, confused, wondering where his sibling is and what's happening, why he needs to wear oxygen. And then, that's when it dawned on us-- we have to figure out a way pretty quickly to help him understand.
他不明白。他只是看到一群这样打扮的人，感到害怕、困惑，想知道他的亲人在哪，发生了什么，为什么他需要吸氧。就在那时，我们意识到——我们必须尽快想办法让他明白。
So they used FaceTime. This was one of the first times Henry Ford used it with COVID patients. It was still early in the pandemic. Dr. Tatem and her team got the man's sister on the phone, on video, so she could explain to her brother how sick he was and why the oxygen was necessary. And then she told the doctors what might help her brother relax.
所以他们使用了FaceTime。这是亨利福特医院首次在新冠病人身上使用这种方法。那是在疫情早期。Tatem医生和她的团队通过视频连线了病人的姐姐，这样她就可以向弟弟解释他病得有多重，以及为什么必须吸氧。然后她告诉医生什么可能有助于她弟弟放松。
His favorite TV channel is this. His favorite TV program is that. He likes this for a snack. He likes these things for activities. And so we were able, pretty quickly, to get those things that he needed to create the environment as close to normal as it can be in an isolation room, if you will.
他最喜欢的电视频道是这个。他最喜欢的电视节目是那个。他喜欢吃这种零食。他喜欢做这些活动。因此，我们很快就能满足他的需求，在隔离病房中创造出尽可能接近正常的环境。
And did that work? Did it calm him down?
那管用吗？他冷静下来了吗？
It absolutely did. It absolutely did.
绝对管用。绝对管用。
Meanwhile, she says his mom was at a different hospital with COVID, and her condition was worsening. His sister was monitoring them both from home and calling their brother all the time to check on him and keep his spirits up.
与此同时，她说他的母亲也在另一家医院治疗新冠，病情在恶化。他的姐姐在家同时关注着他们俩，并不时打电话给弟弟查看情况，给他打气。
Was she giving updates to her brother about how their mom was doing? Or was that a bridge too far?
她有向她弟弟更新母亲的情况吗？还是说那太残忍了？
That was a bridge too far.
那太残忍了。
Oh, wow. So he really didn't know that his mom was sick, basically?
哦，天哪。所以他基本上完全不知道他母亲生病了？
No. And the sad thing in this case is actually, because the sister who was his caregiver was both taking care of him and his mother, she got ill.
是的。这个案例令人悲伤的是，由于身为照顾者的姐姐既照顾他又照顾母亲，她自己也病倒了。
The staff found this out by accident. One day, they needed the sister's help.
医护人员偶然发现了这一点。有一天，他们需要姐姐的帮助。
And we kept calling and couldn't get an answer. And then, after multiple attempts, another sibling called and said, hey, I'm so-and-so's other sister. And the reason why you haven't been able to get in touch with my sister is because she has now passed away.
我们一直打电话，但没人接听。后来，经过多次尝试，另一个兄弟姐妹打来电话说，嘿，我是某某的另一个姐姐。你们之所以无法联系上我的姐姐，是因为她已经去世了。
Oh, my goodness. Oh, my goodness.
哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。
I'm not really sure if he knows that his sister, who is his caregiver, has passed away.
我不太确定他是否知道照顾他的姐姐已经去世了。
Oh, my goodness.
哦，我的天哪。
Yeah, because it-- so it was devastating to us, as a team, when we heard about that. Because again, this is the aftermath of what we're seeing. And to know that his sister, who spent her life making sure that he was OK, wound up dying from the very disease that we're treating him for was really, really difficult.
是的，这对我们团队来说是一个沉重的打击。因为这再次证明了我们所见的后果。想到照顾他一生确保他安好的姐姐，竟然死于我们正在治疗他的同一种疾病，这真的非常非常困难。
[SNIFFLING]
[抽泣]
And this was what we'd been seeing over and over again-- the person who gets admitted to the ICU who tells us, yeah, well, my spouse is also sick, or my daughter or son is also sick. We've had instances where we've had multiple family members of just one family in our ICUs. So it's really difficult, and something I don't think any of us could have even emotionally prepared ourselves for.
这就是我们反复看到的情况——被送进ICU的人会告诉我们，是的，我的配偶也病了，或者我的女儿或儿子也病了。我们甚至遇到过一家人有多位成员都在我们ICU的情况。这真的很困难，我想我们任何人在情感上都无法准备好面对这一切。
At its peak, COVID spread through Detroit like an invisible wildfire, entire homes, neighborhoods unrecognizable afterwards. The man Dr. Tatem treated was moved to rehab to recover from what COVID did to his body. What it did to his life is different. There's no rehab for that.
在疫情高峰期，新冠像一场无形的野火席卷了底特律，让整个家庭、整个社区在事后变得面目全非。Tatem医生治疗的那位男子被送往康复中心，以恢复身体功能。但这对他生活的影响是另一回事。那没有康复中心。
Robyn Semien is a producer on our show.
Robyn Semien是我们节目的制片人。
Act One, "Pod Bless America." In April, when we first started talking to the staff at Henry Ford, the intensive care unit was struggling with something they had never seen before-- all these patients who were just not getting better. These were COVID patients who would either die, or they'd stay stuck on ventilators for weeks, and the staff had no idea how to get them off. When that doctor, Rana Awdish-- who we heard at the beginning of the show-- would circulate through the hospital, talking to staff and checking in, they all knew that she has a very particular approach to medicine and to patient care.
第一幕，“上帝保佑美国”。四月份，当我们第一次开始与亨利福特的员工交谈时，ICU正处于一种前所未有的挣扎中——所有的病人都不见好转。这些新冠病人要么去世，要么在呼吸机上困了好几周，而医护人员根本不知道如何让他们脱离呼吸机。当那位我们在节目开头提到的Rana Awdish医生在医院巡视、与员工交流并查看情况时，他们都知道她对医学和病人护理有一种非常独特的方法。
Miki Meek, welcome back.
Miki Meek，欢迎回来。
Hey again, Ira. So yeah, Rana's whole approach to medicine comes out of an experience she had back in 2008. She was a doctor here at Henry Ford, and then she landed in her own ICU as a patient. She had multi-system organ failure and went on a ventilator. And she told me her co-workers acted like she couldn't hear them, but she actually could.
嘿，Ira。是的，Rana对医学的全部看法源于2008年的一次经历。当时她是亨利福特的一名医生，后来她自己住进了ICU作为病人。她出现了多器官功能衰竭，并戴上了呼吸机。她告诉我，同事们表现得好像她听不见他们说话，但实际上她听得见。
What shocked and upset me the most was overhearing a resident in the hallway say, she's trying to die on me. Hearing in the operating room, she's circling the drain.
最让我震惊和难过的是，听到走廊里的一位住院医生说：“她快要死在我手上了。”在手术室里听到：“她已经没救了。”
That sounds so scary to hear that.
听起来太可怕了。
Yeah. It was so difficult to imagine my own recovery when everyone around me was talking about me as if I was dying. But, you know, I had said similar things.
是的。当周围每个人都谈论我好像快死了一样时，想象自己的康复是如此困难。但你知道，我也说过类似的话。
She's circling the drain?
“她已经没救了”？
Yeah. It was a culture of bravado, and it was showing that you were untouched by suffering. It was that it didn't matter. One of the things I've always felt sort of ashamed about is that our patients have been telling us these things for years.
是的。那是一种虚张声势的文化，表现出你没有受到痛苦的影响。这无关紧要。我一直感到羞愧的一件事是，我们的病人们多年来一直在告诉我们这些事。
When she recovered, she returned to her job at the hospital with a new mindset. It was all about empathy-- that empathy would make her a better doctor, not worse, which was the opposite of her training. She'd been taught that too much feeling clouds a doctor's judgment. She and a small team revamped the way the whole system talks to patients, and Rana wrote a book about her experience that's now used in medical schools.
康复后，她带着新的心态回到了医院的工作岗位。一切都是为了共情——共情会让她成为更好的医生，而不是更差，这与她受到的训练背道而驰。她被教导说，过多的情感会影响医生的判断力。她和一小队人彻底改变了整个系统与病人沟通的方式，Rana还写了一本关于她经历的书，现在被医学院使用。
But when COVID hit their ICU, it became impossible for the staff to do some of the things Rana put in place. Like, before COVID, when someone arrived unconscious or sedated into the ICU, they'd always ask the family, what do you think your loved one would want me to know about them? Families would put up photos and bring in quilts, personalize the rooms. And the staff, they liked that. They really wanted to get to know the person they'd be caring for. But under COVID, all that was impossible. Families could no longer come in and get to know the staff.
但当新冠袭击他们的ICU时，员工们无法做到Rana推行的一些措施。比如，在新冠之前，当有人无意识或被镇静进入ICU时，他们总是会问家人：你认为你的挚爱想让我知道关于他们的什么？家属们会贴上照片，带来被子，让房间个性化。医护人员喜欢那样。他们真心想了解他们要照顾的人。但在新冠疫情下，这一切都不可能了。家属们不能再进来了解工作人员。
I had one nurse tell me just yesterday, I feel like all of my patients are the same.
昨天刚有一位护士告诉我，我觉得所有的病人都一样。
What does that mean, all the same?
什么意思，都一样？
In this case, they all have COVID pneumonia, they're all proned, they're all on the ventilator. And so there was the risk of depersonalization for the patients.
在这种情况下，他们都有新冠肺炎，他们都处于俯卧位，他们都在呼吸机上。因此，病人存在去个人化的风险。
She said getting to know their patients was a part of their job that they really got a lot of satisfaction out of, but they didn't totally realize that until COVID took it away.
她说，了解病人是让他们获得巨大满足感的工作一部分，但他们直到新冠夺走这一切时才完全意识到。
This change throughout the hospital was biggest for the nurses. They're the ones who spend the most time with COVID patients. And our next story is about the nursing staff in Pod Four.
整个医院的这种变化对护士来说影响最大。他们是花最多时间与新冠病人在一起的人。我们的下一个故事是关于四号病区护理人员的。
The ICU in Henry Ford is broken up into these pods. Pod Four was the front line in the hospital's COVID-19 effort. It was the very first pod designated as all coronavirus patients before the other ICU pods also became all COVID, all the time. Ben Calhoun spent weeks talking to the nurses in Pod Four.
亨利福特的ICU被分成了几个区。四号病区是该医院新冠抗疫工作的最前线。它是第一个被指定为全新冠病人的病区，之后其他ICU病区也都变成了全新冠病房。Ben Calhoun花了数周时间与四号病区的护士们交谈。
By mid-April, the nurses in Pod Four had adapted to the alternate universe of COVID-19, at least in certain ways. What I mean-- take just the PPE. That's the personal protective equipment they had to wear to go into COVID rooms. This was a high-stakes thing.
到了四月中旬，四号病区的护士们至少在某些方面适应了新冠病毒带来的异世界。我的意思是，就拿个人防护装备（PPE）来说。这是进入新冠房间所必须穿戴的。这是一件高风险的事情。
At this point, people had seen 10 ICU staff get COVID. Two colleagues were on ventilators. One nurse had died. Some people got superstitious about "I always put on my gloves in this order." "I always wear a scrub cap under the paper cap, and then I won't get sick."
当时，人们已经看到10名ICU员工感染了新冠。两名同事正在使用呼吸机。一名护士已经去世。有些人对“我总是按这个顺序戴手套”产生了迷信。“我总是把防菌帽戴在纸帽下面，这样我就不会生病。”
What I didn't get about the PPE until talking to the nurses in Pod Four was the mundane, relentless, crazy-making-ness of the very gear keeping them safe. This arduous ritual of rubber gloves, tie-up gowns, P100 respirators that look like gas masks, clear plastic face shields. It took five minutes to put it on to go into a room, five to eight minutes to take it off when you come out. You might have to do this as many as two dozen or more times every single shift.
在与四号病区的护士交谈前，我没理解关于PPE的那些琐碎、无情且令人抓狂的事情。这是维持安全的装备。这套穿戴橡胶手套、系带防护服、看起来像防毒面具的P100呼吸器、透明塑料面罩的艰巨仪式。穿上它进入房间需要五分钟，出来时脱下它需要五到八分钟。每个班次你可能需要重复两打或更多次。
How long it took to get into a room because of all the PPE is actually a good example of how COVID changed what it was like for people to do even just the basic and normal parts of their jobs. Evan Guffey is a nurse in Pod Four. He says you have these ICU rooms with windows out onto the hallway.
由于所有PPE，进入房间需要多长时间，实际上是一个很好的例子，说明新冠是如何改变了人们工作的基本和正常部分。Evan Guffey是四号病区的一名护士。他说你有这些通向走廊有窗户的ICU房间。
Like, all shift long, you hear people banging on the glass windows.
就像，整个班次你都能听到人们在敲玻璃窗。
[SHARP BANGING ON GLASS]
[重重地敲击玻璃]
Because they need-- they went into the room, and they forgot their supplies to draw blood, or they forgot one medication. So--
因为他们需要——他们进了房间，却忘了带抽血的用品，或者忘了某种药物。所以——
OH, so that's a regular sound?
哦，那是个常态声音？
Yes, it's very irritating, but we're all doing it to each other.
是的，很烦人，但我们所有人都在互相干扰。
[LAUGHS] So there's a little bit of a boom, boom, boom-- oh, not again?
[笑] 所以有点“咚，咚，咚”——哦，又是这样？
Yep, yep.
是的。
It was hard, in the new world of COVID, to even communicate with these patients, to explain where they were and what was happening, and to reassure them, and to connect with them in the way that they're used to, the way Rana Awdish talks about. They were still puzzling out the ways to do that.
在新冠的新世界里，即使是与这些病人沟通，解释他们在哪里，发生了什么，安抚他们，并以Rana Awdish所说的方式与他们建立联系，也变得很困难。他们仍在摸索着实现这一目标的方法。
These patients, many of them were sedated, alone in a room with the nonstop sound of the ventilator, which is loud. It's like a vacuum. So nurses had to shout through their P100 masks-- which is like a gas mask-- and a clear plastic face shield over the roar of the ventilator.
这些病人，许多被镇静了，独自一人在房间里，伴随着呼吸机的持续声音，那声音很大。就像真空吸尘器一样。所以护士们必须戴着P100口罩——那就像防毒面具——和透明塑料面罩，在呼吸机的咆哮中通过大喊大叫来交流。
Hey, sir, do you know where you are right now? You're at Henry Ford Hospital in Detroit. Do you know that? OK.
嘿，先生，你知道你现在在哪吗？你在底特律的亨利福特医院。你知道吗？好吧。
Now, it's-- really, you're speaking through your eyes, because that's really all they can see.
现在，你真的必须用你的眼睛说话，因为那是他们能看到的唯一东西。
Anthony Valeri, another nurse in Pod Four.
Anthony Valeri，四号病区的另一位护士。
You've got to speak through your eyes, because they can't see it. Or you just explain to them that you're smiling. Think how many times I've said that. I said, I'm saying good morning with a smile on my face right now.
你得通过眼睛表达，因为他们看不见你的嘴。或者你只是向他们解释你在笑。想想我有多少次说过这句话。我说，我现在面带微笑和你说早安。
You know what you're here for? You're being treated for COVID-19, the coronavirus, right now, OK? Are you in any pain right now?
你知道你在这儿是为了什么吗？你现在正在接受新冠病毒治疗，对吧？你现在有什么疼痛感吗？
In April, a month and a half into all of this, the nurses from Pod Four seem like people who are in the throes of a crisis, but also like people who are used to crises. The first time I talked to Evan, I asked how he was holding up.
四月份，这一切发生了一个半月后，四号病区的护士们看起来就像处于危机中，但也像习惯了危机的人。第一次和Evan交谈时，我问他坚持得怎么样。
I'm good, yeah. I have a good ability to leave work at work. So the second I leave, I can just not think about it. But I'm holding up good.
我很好，真的。我有很好的能力把工作留在工作里。所以一旦我离开，我就不会再想它了。但我坚持得很好。
Sarah Davis is another nurse in Pod Four. She'd been hoping to take on extra shifts because her husband lost his job thanks to COVID. But you ask how she's doing, she's got the same kind of ICU nurse toughness, which I sort of grew up around. My mom was a neonatal ICU nurse. She talks like Evan, who talks like Sarah.
Sarah Davis是四号病区的另一位护士。她一直希望多接班，因为她丈夫因新冠失去了工作。但如果你问她过得怎么样，她有着同样的ICU护士的坚韧，我从小就围绕着这种人长大。我妈妈是新生儿ICU护士。她的说话方式就像Evan，像Sarah。
I think what I do and most of us do, you're in the ICU, things are hard. What I say is, you put your pants on and you do it. You can't complain about it. That's going to make it worse. And you just-- you've got to do it.
我认为我和我们大多数人所做的是，你在ICU，事情很艰难。我的原则是，你把裤子穿上，把事做了。你不能抱怨。那只会让事情变得更糟。你就是——你必须去做。
By May, a month later, things change. Now it seems likely that Pod Four patients, who have been stuck on life support for weeks, most of them would probably never recover. Evan was used to helping patients get better, or giving them a dignified death. Now he felt like he was seeing too many situations that were neither.
到了五月，一个月后，情况变了。现在看来，四号病区的病人们，被困在生命支持系统上几周了，大多数人可能永远不会康复了。Evan习惯于帮助病人好转，或者给予他们有尊严的死亡。现在他觉得他看到的太多情况既不是康复也不是尊严死亡。
The nurses had not seen this coming. Sarah Davis told me she'd braced herself for the surge, but nobody envisioned this part.
护士们没想到会这样。Sarah Davis告诉我她为激增做好了心理准备，但没人预见到这一部分。
You know, you go to work because you want to help people. These patients-- any patients-- are why we go to work in the morning.
你知道，你去工作是因为你想帮助别人。这些病人——任何病人——是我们早上上班的原因。
Yeah.
是的。
And when we can't-- when we can't help somebody, or we're just helping them just get through the day, when a lot of this-- and I don't want this to sound the wrong way-- but we know that they're probably not going to make it out of there, right?
而当我们不能——当我们不能帮助某人，或者我们只是帮他们熬过一天，当这一切的大部分——我不想让这听起来不对劲——但我们知道他们可能不会从那里出来，对吧？
Right.
对。
So-- and I feel like I'm a person optimistic by nature, too.
所以——我觉得我天性也是一个乐观主义者。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
And recently, I feel that-- because I feel like I have changed. I'm more of like-- my husband is a realist and I'm an optimist. And now I feel like we're changing places.
最近，我觉得——因为我觉得我变了。我更像是——我丈夫是个现实主义者，我是个乐观主义者。现在我觉得我们互换了位置。
When I talk to Evan Guffey in May, he tells me about what he's struggling with the most-- that families are continuing to tell them to do everything they can to save patients, which he gets. But there's a patient who typifies what he's seeing-- a man, several underlying health issues, who's been stuck on life support for weeks. He's heavily sedated, breathing tube down his throat.
当我在五月与Evan Guffey交谈时，他告诉我他最纠结的是什么——家属们不断告诉他们尽一切可能挽救病人，这他能理解。但有一位病人代表了他所看到的典型情况——一名男子，有多种基础健康问题，在生命支持系统上被困了好几周。他被深度镇静，喉咙里插着呼吸管。
Eventually, the man's kidneys give out, so he's on constant dialysis. His lungs also give out. And even when they stop sedating him, he remains unresponsive.
最终，该男子的肾脏衰竭了，所以他在进行持续透析。他的肺也衰竭了。即使他们停止给他镇静，他仍然没有反应。
It's like, what are we doing here? We're just continuing to make these people suffer, in a way. It's tough to see those people suffering every day, hooked up to all of these different lines and tubes, and they're essentially unresponsive. And we know if we were to cut a couple of the interventions off, they would pass away very quickly.
就像，我们在这儿做什么呢？在某种程度上，我们只是在继续让这些人受苦。每天看到这些人受苦，身上连着各种不同的管子，而他们基本上毫无反应，这很难受。我们知道如果我们要切断其中几个干预措施，他们会很快离世。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
So I think it causes a lot of frustration with the nursing staff. Because we feel like we're prolonging the inevitable.
所以我认为这引起了护理人员的很多挫败感。因为我们觉得我们在拖延不可避免的结果。
Some of the frustration got brought up yesterday. We had one of our nurses talking with our physicians about, well, when is enough? When are we done?
昨天提出了一些挫败感。我们的一位护士和医生谈到了：好吧，什么时候才算够了？我们什么时候才算做完了？
Evan means that the caring thing would be to let them die.
Evan的意思是，有爱心的做法是让他们离世。
I don't know, Ben. I don't know.
我不知道，Ben。我不知道。
It sounds like everyone, from what I could tell from the rounding, they're just really frustrated. They feel like they're torturing people now.
从我所能看到的查房情况来看，每个人似乎都非常沮丧。他们觉得他们现在在折磨人。
They do, very much. I actually was--
他们确实非常这样觉得。实际上我当时——
Around the same time, Rana Awdish checked in with Erin Dicks, Evan and Sarah's boss. They were standing outside the nurse's break room, talking about exactly what Evan was saying.
大约在同一时间，Rana Awdish询问了Evan和Sarah的老板Erin Dicks。他们站在护士休息室外，谈论着Evan所说的内容。
Because they feel like they're doing wrong.
因为他们觉得他们在做错事。
Yeah.
是的。
They feel like they're preventing the inevitable, and everything that we do is not doing anything. And they're like, this isn't right. Like, they feel-- they start to feel guilty.
他们觉得他们在阻碍不可避免的事情，而我们所做的一切都没有产生任何作用。他们觉得，这不对。他们开始感到内疚。
Yeah.
是的。
Like they're just keeping somebody alive when there's nothing we do is changing any outcome, you know?
就像他们只是在维持某人的生命，而我们做的任何事都不能改变任何结果，你知道吗？
No, I completely understand that feeling. You know, there's no way--
不，我完全理解那种感觉。你知道，没有办法——
They talk about how Pod Four nurses are stuck in the worst position in medicine. They're caught in the middle between patients who they worry are suffering, who are clearly dying, and their families, who are holding out hope.
他们谈论四号病区的护士是如何陷入医学中最糟糕的位置的。他们夹在那些他们担心正在受苦、明显正在死亡的病人，以及那些仍抱有希望的家属中间。
Because that's-- they don't understand it.
因为那样——他们不理解。
It's so abstract.
这太抽象了。
Yeah.
是的。
We wouldn't believe any of this if we weren't here, right?
如果不是亲临现场，我们谁也不会相信这些，对吧？
No. No, it's hard. I mean, you don't. Unless you're sitting there day in and day out and living it every day, you don't understand it. You can't have the feelings that we all have. And so it's--
不。不，这很难。我是说，你不会相信的。除非你日复一日地坐在那里经历它，否则你不理解。你不能拥有我们所有人都有的那些感受。所以这是——
I've been wondering if there's anything we should try to prepare to do differently, maybe before the next wave.
我一直在想是否有什么我们需要准备尝试采取不同做法的，也许是在下一波浪潮之前。
I know, which is going to come.
我知道，它肯定会来。
I hate to even say it.
我甚至讨厌说出这句话。
I know, I know.
我知道，我知道。
Like, if there are different timelines for these conversations.
比如，如果这些谈话有不同的时间表。
By "these conversations," Rana means conversations with patients' families. She wonders if doctors and nurses need to change the language they're using with them, when a patient isn't getting better.
通过“这些谈话”，Rana是指与病人亲属的谈话。她想知道，当病人病情没有好转时，医生和护士是否需要改变他们使用的语言。
We were talking about this the other day. I think it's how we say things. Instead of saying-- when they're that sick, instead of saying, we've seen progress today, maybe we say, we've seen a change today. And this is what we've seen.
我们前几天就在谈论这个。我认为是关于我们说话的方式。当他们病得那么重时，与其说“我们今天看到了进展”，也许我们可以说“我们今天看到了变化”。这就是我们所看到的。
Because it creates false hope.
因为它制造了虚假的希望。
Right. And so not to-- I don't want to instill that, like, oh my god, they're getting better, because they're still so crazy sick. But if we say it differently--
对。所以我不想灌输那种——哦天哪，他们正在好转，因为他们依然病得那么厉害。但如果我们换种说法——
Yes, because we're so eager to give good news, right? We want to, and so we--
是的，因为我们太渴望传达好消息了，对吧？我们想这样做，所以我们——
You almost need that.
你几乎需要那种心态。
Yeah. But sometimes, it's false.
是的。但有时，那是虚假的。
Yeah. Yeah, because they can change.
是的。是的，因为他们会改变。
No, that's a really wise insight.
不，这是一个非常明智的见解。
Yeah, they can change so rapidly. So I think that's the challenge.
是的，他们可能会迅速发生变化。所以我认为这就是挑战。
We're asking a lot of everyone. A lot.
我们对每个人都有很高的要求。真的很高。
Yeah.
是的。
That same week-- this is week nine-- one of the nurses I talked to, Sarah Davis, she had a day where two patients died, and neither of them had family in the room with them. The first was a man who was intubated, so he couldn't speak. Sarah stood with the doctor and held an iPad wrapped in a plastic bag in front of the face of this dying man as a woman said goodbye to him.
同一周——这是第九周——我谈过的一位护士Sarah Davis，有一天有两个病人去世了，他们房间里都没有家人陪着。第一个是一位插管的男子，所以他无法说话。Sarah站在医生旁边，在这个垂死的男人面前举着一个用塑料袋包裹的iPad，看着女人对他道别。
And just hearing that conversation, with that woman who was talking to the patient who couldn't speak back to her, just saying how much she loved him, and that it was a pleasure to have him, to have him in her life. And there was just really-- just so much sadness.
听到那段对话，那个无法回应的女人对病人说她有多爱他，说能拥有他的人生是她的荣幸。真的有——太多的悲伤了。
In normal times, Sarah wouldn't even be witnessing this kind of private moment. Families would come into the room. Doctors and nurses would leave. The second death-- this was the same shift-- Sarah and others in Pod Four gathered outside the room of a man who was dying alone, and they prayed with the man's son, who was on speakerphone.
在正常时期，Sarah甚至不会见证这种私人时刻。家属们会来到房间。医生和护士会离开。第二次死亡——这是同一个班次——Sarah和四号病区的其他人聚集在一个孤独离世的男人的病房外，他们通过免提电话与男人的儿子一起祈祷。
So that-- that was hard.
所以这——那很难。
Probably less than an hour after that, Sarah says, the other patient, the man with the iPad, a couple family members were supposed to be there when he died. But things went wrong. The family told the hospital, take his ventilator tube out, and we'll be there to say goodbye at 7:30. So not long before 7:30, Sarah was in the room, and he was extubated. But then, this man starts dying much faster than normal, and his family is not there yet.
在那之后可能不到一小时，Sarah说，另一个病人，那个iPad病人的家属本应在他去世时在场的。但事情出错了。家人告诉医院：把他的呼吸机管子拔掉，我们在7:30会来道别。所以7:30之前不久，Sarah在房间里，他被拔除了插管。但随后，这个男人开始比正常情况快得多地走向死亡，而他的家人还没到。
So I was waiting for them to come. But while-- I was waiting for them to come and I was making him comfortable. And I stayed with him while he died, before his family came. And he ended up passing right before his family came.
所以我一直在等他们来。但当——我在等他们来的时候，我在让他感到舒适。在他去世之前，我一直陪着他，在他家人到来之前。结果他在家人到来之前就去世了。
I can't stress enough how different this is from Sarah's normal job, being alone with a dying patient. Since COVID, it's common for nurses, though, in hospitals everywhere. With this man, Sarah stood by herself, and held his hand, and stroked his head. She told him he did a good job, as she stared through the window, hoping desperately that his family would appear.
我怎么强调Sarah正常的职业与这之间的不同都不为过，陪伴一个垂死的病人。然而，自从新冠以来，这在世界各地的医院对护士来说很常见。在这个男人身上，Sarah独自一人站在旁边，握着他的手，抚摸着他的头。她告诉他他做得很好，同时盯着窗外，绝望地希望他的家人能出现。
And then I came home. And you'd appreciate this, because you have kids. And I thought I was OK. And I had come home. My kids are normally asleep. So I just peeked in the room that they were in. And they both were looking like they were sleeping. I was just looking at them, crying. [LAUGHS]
然后我回家了。你会理解的，因为你有孩子。我以为我没事。我回家了。孩子们通常都睡了。所以我只是偷偷看了看他们所在的房间。他们看起来都睡着了。我看着他们，哭了出来。[笑]
And then they were both up. And my son was like, oh, are you sad? Then I start bawling my eyes out. And I was like, yeah, it was a sad day.
然后他们都醒了。我儿子说，哦，你伤心吗？然后我开始号啕大哭。我说，是的，今天是很伤心的一天。
And you know, he knows what I do. And we called the virus "the world bug." And he asked if somebody died. And so I told him, yeah. And just in six-year-old terms, that I was with him, and that he was comfortable. And so that was probably the saddest day that I've had.
你知道，他知道我是做什么的。我们将病毒称为“世界虫子”。他问是否有人去世。所以我告诉他，是的。我用六岁孩子能听懂的话告诉他，我陪着他，他感到很舒适。所以那可能是我经历过最伤心的一天。
I'm so sorry. I can't imagine.
我很抱歉。我无法想象。
Yeah. It just really-- it just really sucks.
是的。这真的——真的太糟糕了。
Around the same time, early May, COVID cases have finally receded enough that parts of the hospital are starting to go back to normal. Non-COVID floors are reopening. People who've been furloughed are coming back to work. Specialists who'd been assigned to COVID ICUs go back to their normal jobs. Even the deli reopens.
大约在同一时间，五月初，新冠病例终于减少到医院部分区域开始恢复正常的程度。非新冠楼层正在重新开放。被休假的人正在重返工作岗位。被分配到新冠ICU的专家们回到了他们的正常工作岗位。连熟食店也重新开放了。
Some people tell Rana that they're surprised to find themselves feeling upset about other parts of the hospital going back to normal-- not because they're jealous, but because it makes them feel like this awful thing they'd all gone through is being erased. And for the staff of Pod Four with their 16 ICU beds, they're still 100% COVID patients. And the COVID patients are going to keep coming. Rana talked to Miki about it.
有些人告诉Rana，他们惊讶地发现自己对医院其他部分恢复正常感到心烦——不是因为嫉妒，而是因为这让他们觉得他们共同经历的这件可怕的事情正在被抹去。而对于拥有16张ICU床位的四号病区的工作人员来说，他们仍然100%是新冠病人。而且新冠病人会不断涌入。Rana与Miki谈到了这件事。
I'm not seeing relief. I'm seeing sadness. And that's the thing that's starting to settle in, is this is ours.
我没有看到解脱。我看到了悲伤。而这就是开始沉淀下来的东西，这是属于我们的。
The relief valve isn't coming any time soon.
减压阀短时间内不会到来。
Right. The group of, I think, doctors and nurses who are caring for these patients are going to be the group of doctors and nurses caring for these patients for the next two years. And I don't know if we've wrapped our minds around yet.
对。我认为照顾这些病人的那一组医生和护士，将会是未来两年照顾这些病人的同一组医生和护士。我不知道我们是否已经做好心理准备了。
COVID was this brutal new normal, stretching out all the way to the horizon of the foreseeable future.
新冠是这种残酷的新常态，一直延伸到可预见的未来的地平线。
Ben Calhoun, he's one of the producers on our show.
Ben Calhoun，他是我们节目的制片人之一。
Coming up, OK, your dad comes off a ventilator. His life has been saved. What is the very first thing he says to you? We hear what happened in one family. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
即将到来，好吧，你爸爸撤掉了呼吸机。他的生命得到了拯救。他跟你说的第一句话是什么？我们听听一个家庭发生了什么。稍后，在《芝加哥公共广播》我们的节目继续进行时。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, "The Reprieve," stories of coronavirus at Henry Ford Hospital in Detroit-- not when they were busiest and things were the worst, but in the weeks since, as the number of cases steadily declined. What you're hearing this hour is when things were less awful. I should say, before we go any further, that, of course, this past week, COVID-19 cases across the country have been on the rise, including in Michigan.
《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目，“暂时的解脱”，底特律亨利福特医院关于冠状病毒的故事——不是他们最繁忙、最糟糕的时候，而是之后几周，随着病例数量稳步下降。你在这个小时听到的是情况不那么糟糕的时候。我应该说，在我们继续之前，当然，过去一周，全国范围内的新冠病例一直在上升，包括密歇根州。
Anyway, in the first half of our show, we focused mostly on the staff of the hospital. In this half, we turn to the people that they tried to save. We've arrived at Act Two of our show-- Act Two, "Stan's Good Day."
总之，在节目的上半部分，我们主要关注的是医院的工作人员。在这一部分，我们转向他们试图拯救的人们。我们已经进入节目的第二幕——第二幕，“斯坦的美好一天”。
And we found out about the patient in this story from a recording made by a young doctor named Stan Linder who worked in the intensive care unit during the second year of his training at Henry Ford, studying his specialties, nephrology and critical care. He said that he would binge Oreos to cope with the stress. "I am not going to make my summer body goals," he told one of our producers.
我们从一位年轻医生Stan Linder制作的录音中了解到了这个故事里的病人。他在亨利福特接受培训的第二年就在重症监护室工作，攻读他的专业——肾脏科和重症监护。他说他会暴饮奥利奥来应对压力。“我无法达到我夏季身体的目标了，”他告诉我们的制片人之一。
Anyway, our producer Emanuele Berry put this together. It begins with a voice memo that Stan recorded for us on his phone.
总之，我们的制片人Emanuele Berry制作了这一部分。它以Stan在手机上为我们录制的一条语音备忘录开始。
This is April 30, 2020. It's 7:30 at night, and I've just finished my last COVID ICU day. I've worked the last 11 days in a row, and it's been sort of a crazy experience.
这是2020年4月30日。晚上7:30，我刚刚完成了最后一个新冠ICU日。我已经连续工作了11天，这是一种疯狂的经历。
And today was really rough-- really rough. I've had some really horrible moments-- horrible moments that I will always remember. And I feel like I'm eventually going to have PTSD from this, which sucks.
今天真的很艰难——真的很艰难。我经历了一些非常可怕的时刻——我将永远记得这些可怕的时刻。我觉得我最终会因为这个而患上创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），这很糟糕。
But one of my best moments in this has definitely been one of my patients-- and I will always remember her for the rest of my life. She was young and pregnant, very along in her pregnancy-- very along. And the first day that I met her, she was struggling to breathe-- like, really struggling to breathe. And you could tell that just by how fast she was breathing.
但在这一切中，我最好的时刻之一绝对是我的其中一位病人——我余生都将记住她。她年轻且怀孕，孕期很长——很长。我遇见她的第一天，她呼吸困难——真的非常困难。仅仅从她呼吸的速度就能看出来。
But she was, in that same moment, comfortable. Her face was total comfort. It was sort of eerie to see how fast she was breathing. 40 to 50 times a minute-- that's very fast. That's almost one breath a second. For you to inhale and exhale that quickly takes a lot of work. It takes a lot of muscle movement to do that. Eventually, someone will tire out, and they will stop breathing.
但在同一时刻，她很安详。她的表情完全是安逸的。看到她呼吸得那么快有点诡异。每分钟40到50次——那是非常快的。几乎每秒一次呼吸。要那么快地吸气和呼气需要做很多功课。这需要大量的肌肉运动。最终，有人会累坏，然后停止呼吸。
Before the patient ended up intubated, I had to have her call her husband on the phone so we could have a conversation about what would happen, not only to my patient, but also her unborn child. That's an extreme conversation to have within five minutes of meeting a person.
在病人最终插管前，我必须让她给丈夫打电话，这样我们才能谈谈会发生什么，不仅是针对我的病人，还有她未出生的孩子。在见到一个人五分钟内进行这种谈话是非常极端的。
And so she was on the ventilator for seven days and ended up getting extubated on that seventh day. And she did great for a couple hours after she got extubated. And then, by noon, everything went haywire. And she was adamant, adamant, that she would not-- she absolutely did not want the tube back in. And I pleaded with her, because her heart rate was up, she was breathing so fast. I thought she was going to tire out again. And she was adamant. She's like, no, I do not want that tube back in.
所以她戴了七天呼吸机，并在第七天成功拔除了插管。她拔管后的几小时内表现很好。然后，到中午，一切都乱套了。她非常坚决，坚决不要把管子再插回去。我恳求她，因为她的心率加快，呼吸如此急促。我以为她会再次累坏。而她很坚决。她说，不，我绝对不要把那管子再放回去。
And then, two days later, she had a vaginal delivery. I have never-- she had a vaginal delivery two days after getting extubated from a ventilator for seven days. That blows my mind. It blows my mind, blows my mind. A miracle! Amazing!
然后，两天后，她进行了阴道分娩。我从未——她在戴了七天呼吸机并拔管后两天进行了阴道分娩。这让我震惊。这让我震惊，让我震惊。一个奇迹！太神奇了！
My patient survived. My patients survived. I had two, two patients in that room, and they both came out healthy. And a lot of my patients, especially in the beginning of all this, didn't. So I'm really glad I've had this experience right at the end.
我的病人活下来了。我的病人活下来了。在那间房里我有两个，两个病人，她们都健康地出来了。我的许多病人，特别是在这一切开始的时候，并没有活下来。所以我很高兴在最后得到了这个经历。
What's the baby like?
宝宝怎么样？
Well, she's-- [LAUGHS] She's a really tough baby.
嗯，她——[笑] 她是一个非常坚强的宝宝。
Why?
为什么？
She's, like-- she want to be in arms all day. And if you don't do what she wants at the moment, she gets really mad, and she give you this mad face. And it's funny that she's-- [LAUGHS]
她，就像——她整天想被人抱。如果你当时不顺着她，她会变得很生气，并且露出这种生气的表情。她竟然是这样，很有趣——[笑]
You don't know what I went through for you, child?
你不知道我为了你经历了什么吗，孩子？
Yeah. I'm like, OK. Yeah, I'm like, OK, you really have a bad attitude with me.
是的。我心想，好吧。是的，我心想，好吧，你确实对我态度很不好。
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
This is Francesca Miranda Aquino. She worked as a chef at PF Chang's. She's originally from Puerto Rico. Now she lives in Mexicantown, Southwest Detroit, with her husband, who's a preacher, their two-year-old son, and now her newborn daughter, who does not seem to appreciate what her mom went through to bring her into the world.
这位是Francesca Miranda Aquino。她在PF Chang's当厨师。她原籍波多黎各。现在她和丈夫（一位牧师）、两岁的儿子住在美国底特律西南部，现在还有一个刚出生的女儿，她似乎不感激她妈妈为了把她带到这个世界上所经历的一切。
Francesca remembers a few things from her time in the ICU. She remembers how hopeless the place seemed when they wheeled her in. It felt like breathing in death, she says. She remembers how, days later, when she came to, no one else in her pod was awake. And she remembers the moment Stan talked about, where she refused to be re-intubated. It was the morning of the 21st. The tube had only been out for a few hours.
Francesca记得一些关于她在ICU的时间。她记得当他们推她进去时那个地方看起来多么绝望。她说，感觉就像吸入了死亡。她记得几天后，当她清醒过来时，病区里没有其他人醒着。她记得斯坦谈到的那一刻，她拒绝重新插管。那是21号的早上。管子才拔出来几个小时。
And I remember that another doctor came in, and he told me that my heart was beating really fast and my blood pressure was really, really high. And he told me that, really, they need to put the tube back in again, and I need to relax. And I told him, no.
我记得另一位医生进来了，他告诉我我的心跳非常快，血压也非常非常高。他告诉我，真的，他们需要再次把管子放回去，我需要放松。我告诉他，不。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I told him, no, you're not going to put those tubes back again. And I told him, it's just passed one hour where they took out the tubes on me, and now you want to put the tubes back on me? No. You just need to give me time. That's what I told him. You need to give me time where my body starts reacting normal. And he was like, OK.
我告诉他，不，你不会再把那些管子放回去了。我告诉他，拔出管子才过了一个小时，现在你们想把管子重新插回我身上？不。你只需要给我时间。我就是那样告诉他的。你需要给我时间，让我的身体开始做出正常的反应。然后他说，好吧。
Billions and billions of people have had babies. Millions have gotten COVID. Very few people, like Francesca, have done both at the same time.
几十亿人有过孩子。数百万人得过新冠。像Francesca这样同时完成两件事的人很少。
They decided to induce labor, and she chose to do it alone because she thought it would be too dangerous for her family to come to the ICU where everyone had COVID. Remember, she'd only been off the ventilator for two days. She was incredibly weak and could barely raise her legs by herself.
他们决定引产，她选择独自一人完成，因为她认为让家人来到每个人都有新冠的ICU太危险了。记住，她撤掉呼吸机才两天。她虚弱得令人难以置信，自己几乎抬不动腿。
At this point, she's still on oxygen. The doctors wanted her to hold her breath and push, but breathing in general was still tough. And then, once the baby was born, after 25 hours of labor--
在这一点上，她还在吸氧。医生们希望她屏住呼吸并用力，但总体呼吸仍然很困难。然后，孩子出生后，经过25小时的分娩——
So when I had the baby, they really took the baby out of the room, and I didn't get to see my baby after three days.
所以当我生下宝宝时，他们真的把宝宝带出了房间，三天后我才见到我的宝宝。
You didn't get to see the baby for three days?
你三天没见到宝宝？
Yeah, after three days, yeah.
是的，三天后，是的。
Francesca was still recovering from COVID and still in the ICU, so she and the baby were separated. When Francesca was well enough to be moved from the ICU to the general floor, she was told she would have to wear a mask and gloves, but she could hold her child for the first time.
Francesca还在从新冠中恢复，并且还在ICU里，所以她和宝宝分开了。当Francesca身体好到足以从ICU转到普通病房时，她被告知必须戴口罩和手套，但她可以第一次抱她的孩子了。
And I was like, oh my god, I thought I would never hold you. But I felt really happy. And as soon as I was with him in the room, I called my husband on video call, and my husband started crying. And he-- my husband, he's a really emotional person. And he started crying, and then he was really excited. And he put on the phone my son. And my son was watching his sister. It was a really, really good moment.
我说，哦，天哪，我以为我永远抱不到你了。但我感到非常快乐。当我一和他在房间里时，我通过视频通话给我丈夫打了电话，我丈夫开始哭泣。他——我丈夫是个非常感性的人。他开始哭，然后非常兴奋。他让我的儿子也上了电话。我儿子正在看着他的妹妹。那真是非常非常美好的时刻。
What's the baby's name?
宝宝叫什么名字？
Arisbeth.
Arisbeth。
Francesca is at home now. She's not working because she doesn't have childcare, but she's happy that she's no longer being poked and prodded with needles at the hospital. Arisbeth is doing great. She's perfectly healthy. Francesca says she loves kisses from her big brother. She's sleeping through the night and already trying to roll on her tummy.
Francesca现在在家里。她没有工作，因为她没有育儿协助，但她很高兴不用再在医院被针扎来扎去了。Arisbeth表现很好。她完全健康。Francesca说她喜欢哥哥亲吻。她整晚都在睡觉，已经在尝试翻身了。
Emanuele Berry.
Emanuele Berry。
Act Three, "Granger in a Strange Land." So Robert Granger was in Pod Four for three weeks. He got close with one of the nurses, Sarah Davis. She's the nurse that you heard earlier who saw two people die in a single day, the nurse who talked about becoming less of an optimist.
第三幕，“陌生土地上的Granger”。所以Robert Granger在四号病区呆了三周。他和其中一名护士Sarah Davis关系密切。她就是你们早些时候听到的那位亲眼目睹两人在一天内死亡的护士，那位谈论变得不再那么乐观的护士。
She had a special connection with Mr. Granger and attached a lot of hope to his case. They talked about his wife, who died of cancer in January, and how hard his family had taken it. He also talked about his grown daughter, Jocelyn. And as he got sicker, Sarah really pushed him to phone Jocelyn. Here's Sarah.
她与Granger先生有特殊的联系，并对他的病例寄予了很多希望。他们谈论了他一月死于癌症的妻子，以及他的家人是如何承受这些痛苦的。他还谈到了他已成年的女儿Jocelyn。随着他病情加重，Sarah极力推促他给Jocelyn打电话。听听Sarah怎么说。
I was like, we're calling her. No, I don't want to. I was like, we're calling her. [LAUGHS] But what was really interesting about him and his daughter was, as he was talking to his daughter, he was being so tough, but at the same time, crying. His wife had just passed away, not from COVID. And he was doing everything that he possibly could because he didn't want his daughter to lose Dad.
我说，我们要打给她。他说不，我不想要。我说，我们要打给她。[笑] 但关于他和他的女儿，真正有趣的是，当他跟女儿说话时，他表现得非常坚强，但同时也泪流满面。他的妻子刚去世，不是因为新冠。他正竭尽所能做一切他能做的事，因为他不想让女儿失去父亲。
Emanuele Berry put together this story about Robert Granger and his daughter Jocelyn.
Emanuele Berry制作了这个关于Robert Granger和他女儿Jocelyn的故事。
Jocelyn's in her 20s, and her dad's in his 60s. He works for the city fixing buses. And he called her one Friday and said he needed to go to the hospital.
Jocelyn二十多岁，她爸爸六十多岁。他在市政府负责修理公共汽车。那个周五他打电话给女儿说他需要去医院。
I'm like, that's all I need to know. Hung up, ran down, speeded all my way to his house, because I was scared. I'm like, I think he has it.
我心想，这是我需要知道的全部信息。挂断电话，跑下来，一路飞驰到他家，因为我很害怕。我心想，我想他得了新冠。
Yeah, what was that car ride like?
是啊，那次开车是什么感觉？
He probably was scared, because I probably was driving like the dragster at Cedar Point. It was to the point to where it was-- I'm worried about-- I'm like, I need to get him there, because I'm thinking-- I'm hearing all over the news that they're running out of supplies. And I'm like, I need to get him in there just in case he needs a ventilator. And he was like, um, you know how fast you're going? And I'm like, OK, OK, reality, reality-- and then spiked back up.
他可能很害怕，因为我当时开得就像Cedar Point的赛车。当时的情况是——我担心的是——我心想，我需要把他送到那儿，因为我在想——我在新闻里听说他们快没用品了。我心想，我需要把他送进去，以防他需要呼吸机。他当时问我：嗯，你知道你开得多快吗？我心想，好吧，好吧，回到现实，回到现实——然后又飙升了回去。
And I literally just remember drifting into the emergency, because I've seen the tents. I had my mask on. He was in the back seat, just to social distance from me. And then, the last thing he said to me was, if I get out of here and you're taking me home, don't drive like this when we go back.
我真记得我漂移进了急诊室，因为我看到了帐篷。我戴着口罩。他在后座，只是为了跟我保持社交距离。然后，他对我说的最后一句话是，如果我能从这儿出去，而你带我回家，我们回去时别这么开车。
But she can't take him home. He has COVID, and he's taken to ICU Pod Four. As the days pass, he gets worse. The medications don't seem to work. His breathing becomes more labored. And then, on Jocelyn's birthday--
但她不能带他回家。他得了新冠，被送往ICU四号病区。随着时间流逝，他越来越糟。药物似乎不起作用。他的呼吸变得更加费力。然后，在Jocelyn生日那天——
I get a call from him saying, like, hey, I might be put on a ventilator. And I'm like, no. No, no, no, no. Because the doctors are telling me the last thing they want to do is put them on the ventilators, because most people are not making it out. So I'm freaking out. Then it turns out it was a false alarm.
我接到他打来的电话说，嘿，我可能要戴呼吸机了。我说，不。不，不，不，不。因为医生告诉我他们最不想做的事情就是插上呼吸机，因为大多数人都活不下来。所以我当时吓坏了。结果后来发现那是个虚惊一场。
And then, a few days later, I get a phone call. And he just said, it's not looking so good. And it almost sounded like he whispered it to me, because he couldn't breathe. One of the scariest phone calls of my life. Probably the top second. The first is when he called me to tell me my mother passed. And now, this was the second-worst phone call I've ever received in my life.
几天后，我接到电话。他只是说，看起来不太好。他听起来几乎是在向我耳语，因为他无法呼吸。我一生中最可怕的电话之一。大概排第二。第一是我打电话给我告诉我妈妈去世的时候。现在，这是我一生中接到的第二个最糟糕的电话。
How do you react to that?
你怎么应对的？
When I say it took so much muscle to not have my voice crack because I was getting ready to sob-- I'm like, OK, Dad. I'll talk to you soon.
当我说我用尽了所有力气才没让我的声音颤抖，因为我准备大哭一场时——我说，好吧，爸爸。我会很快和你谈话。
Why didn't you want your voice to crack on the phone or for your dad to hear you getting upset?
为什么你不想在电话里让声音颤抖，也不想让你爸爸听到你心烦？
Because if-- just like my mom, if I worry, he worries.
因为如果——就像我妈妈，如果我担心，他就会担心。
That's what he said about you.
关于你，他也是这么说的。
Is that why you he said he didn't want to-- he had to keep his composure, too?
这也是为什么他表现得不想，不得不保持镇定吗？
Yeah, he didn't want you to worry.
是的，他不想让你担心。
Told her that, you know, I love her, and that I'm about to go on a ventilator and I don't know what's going to happen. And I just told her, let the family know, and talk to our minister. And they came in, and they put me on it.
告诉她，你知道，我爱她，我马上要戴上呼吸机了，不知道会发生什么。我只是告诉她，让家人知道，和我们的牧师谈谈。他们进来了，把我插上了管子。
This is her dad, Robert, though I'm going to call him Mr. Granger, because that's what Sarah Davis called him. And it's just a solid dad name. The nurses told us they often wondered what this all looked like from the patient's side. Here's how it looked for Mr. Granger. When he was rolled into the ICU, he says he felt like he was inside a fishbowl. Lots of windows, lots of people staring at him through those windows, including Sarah Davis.
这是她的爸爸Robert，虽然我要叫他Granger先生，因为Sarah Davis就是这么叫他的。这只是一个很实在的名字。护士们告诉我们，他们经常想知道这一切从病人的角度看是什么样。这就是Granger先生眼中的样子。当他被推进ICU时，他说感觉自己就像在一个鱼缸里。到处都是窗户，许多人透过窗户盯着他，包括Sarah Davis。
Sarah stands out the most. I just remember her, a lot of times, looking through the window and out at the nurses. And one nurse in particular would hold up a little piece of paper and saying, we're praying for you.
Sarah最突出。我只记得她，很多时候，透过窗户看外面。其中一位护士特别会举起一张小纸条说：我们为你祈祷。
As I started getting a little worse, I noticed just the doctors were-- they didn't come in at first. They would just look. They would just look through the window. Look at me, wave, and then look at the meter, at my vitals.
随着我开始稍微恶化，我注意到医生们——他们起初没进来。他们只是看。他们只是透过窗户看。看我，挥手，然后看仪表，看我的生命体征。
What did it feel like to just have people looking?
有人看着你是什么感觉？
I didn't know what to think at first. And then one doctor came in, and he sat down, and he asked me, what did I think? And I say, well, I'm thinking things are not too good.
起初我不知道该怎么想。然后一位医生进来了，他坐下，问我：你在想什么？我说，好吧，我以为情况不太好。
This is when the doctors told Mr. Granger they may have to put him on a ventilator.
这是医生告诉Granger先生他们可能不得不给他戴上呼吸机的时候。
And I said, if I'm on it for a reasonable amount of time and things don't look good, take me off.
我说，如果我戴着它一段时间，情况看起来不好，就把我撤掉。
Was it easy for you to make that decision, or--
做出那个决定容易吗，或者——
No, but it's a decision I wanted to make. I didn't want my daughter to have to make that decision. Going through my head is, at that time, they didn't know whether I was going to make it or not. And the only thing I can think of is, wow, we just went through losing my wife, and my daughter is losing her mother. Now, if she lose me, she's really going to be devastated. Because my daughter, she's an emotional person.
不，但这正是我想要做的决定。我不希望我的女儿不得不做那个决定。当时我脑子里闪过的是，他们不知道我是否能挺过来。我唯一能想到的就是，哇，我们刚刚经历了失去我的妻子，我的女儿正在失去她的母亲。现在，如果她失去我，她真的会崩溃。因为我的女儿，她是个感性的人。
On that phone call about the ventilator, dad was trying to protect his daughter by being tough. Daughter was trying to protect dad by doing the same thing. But neither of them is conscious of this until Sarah, the nurse who was getting to know them both, pointed it out. Here's Jocelyn.
在那次关于呼吸机的电话里，爸爸试图表现得坚强来保护女儿。女儿试图做同样的事来保护爸爸。但他们谁都没有意识到这一点，直到与他们两人都熟悉起来的护士Sarah指出来。听听Jocelyn怎么说。
She just asked me, like, you know, how was it? Like, how did you stay so strong? And I said, girl, when I hung up, I was not strong at all. I let it out. She was like, your dad literally said the same thing. I was like, go figure.
她只是问我：你知道，那是什么感觉？你是怎么保持那么坚强的？我说，姑娘，当我挂断电话时，我一点也不坚强。我发泄了出来。她说，你爸爸确实也说了同样的话。我想：可想而知。
And that's when I realized, I usually-- my mom was the sweetest person ever, and I used to think-- I got the kind of thing where I can't say no to helping people. I used to think I got it from her. I got it from him. And that was just-- it just made me feel more guilty. And I'm like, wow, I really wish I took the time to get closer to you, equally as much as my mom.
就在那时我意识到，我通常——我妈妈是世界上最甜美的人，我曾认为——我能做到那种无法拒绝帮助别人的人的特质，我以为是从她那里得来的。原来是从他那里得来的。这让我感到更加内疚。我想，哇，我真的希望我花时间和你亲近一点，像和我妈妈一样亲近。
For 10 days, he's on a ventilator, and she wonders if she'll ever have more time with them. Jocelyn described this thing that really stuck with me, that when you call into a hospital every day, when you cannot see or talk to your loved one, you live with a sort of picture of them in your head that you're holding onto, even though what's happening to them may be completely different than that image. There's this disconnect.
他戴了10天呼吸机，她想知道自己是否还能有更多时间和他们在一起。Jocelyn描述的那件事真的触动了我：当你每天给医院打电话，当你无法看到或与你的亲人说话时，你的脑海里会一直保存着他们的某种形象，即使正在发生的事情可能与那个形象完全不同。这之间存在脱节。
So when she calls to check in on him a week or so in, in her head, he's sleeping on a vent. But the nurse who answers the phone says, oh, he's off the vent. And he was. She gets him on the phone.
所以当她在大概一周后打电话查询他的情况时，在她脑海里，他是躺着戴呼吸机的。但接电话的护士说，哦，他已经撤掉呼吸机了。确实如此。她在电话里和他谈上了。
And then, like, you know, one of the first things he asked me when he answered the phone to tell me that he was off the ventilator? He literally asked me, did I need any money?
然后，就像，你知道，他接通电话告诉我他撤掉呼吸机后问我的第一件事吗？他竟然问我：你需要钱吗？
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
I'm like, are you serious right now? [LAUGHS] I'm like, no. I'm like-- and it just kind of like-- you know how someone has a personality quirk that just sums up their whole character? That was it. I was like, wow. You literally just died and came back, and the first thing you asked is, do you need any money?
我心想，你现在是认真的吗？[笑] 我心想，不。我心想——这有点像——你知道当某人有一个能总结其全部人格特质的性格怪癖吗？就是那个。我心想，哇。你竟然刚刚死而复生，问的第一件事竟然是：你需要钱吗？
I just remember calling him on April 17, which is my mom's birthday. He was still not conscious. So I asked the nurse, and I'm like, is my dad awake? And she was like, no, he's sedated. And I'm like, OK, good, because today would've been his wife's birthday. I just want to make sure he's not sad or depressed.
我只记得在4月17日打电话给他，那是妈妈的生日。他仍然没有意识。所以我问护士，我心想，我爸爸醒了吗？她说，不，他被镇静了。我说，好吧，太好了，因为今天本来是妻子的生日。我只是想确保他不会难过或沮丧。
After four weeks in the hospital, Mr. Granger was discharged to a rehab center. When he was well enough to come home from there, Jocelyn went to pick him up. She made sure to get all her crying done in the car before she got there.
在医院呆了四周后，Granger先生出院去了康复中心。当他好到可以从那里回家时，Jocelyn去接他。她确保在到达那里之前在车里把所有的眼泪都流干了。
Yeah, I did. I tried not to cry, because I hate crying in front of my dad.
是的，我确实那么做了。我试图不哭，因为我讨厌在我爸爸面前哭。
I do, too. [LAUGHS]
我也是。[笑]
Because I feel like-- yeah.
因为我觉得——是的。
Yeah.
是的。
I really hate crying in front of my-- I don't know what it is. But I don't know. I just hate crying in front of people. But it's just, I really hate crying in front of my dad. So I'm like, don't cry, don't cry. Like, I want my crying out in the car. I was playing all of my sad reuniting songs. So I'm like, OK.
我真的讨厌在爸爸面前哭。我不知道原因。但我不知道。我只是讨厌在别人面前哭。但就是，我真的讨厌在爸爸面前哭。所以我心想，别哭，别哭。我想在车里把哭发泄出来。我放了我所有的悲伤重逢歌曲。所以我心想，好吧。
What were you playing?
你在放什么？
I think-- I'll have to go through my playlist, because I played about, like, 65 songs. Because the problem with me is I can never play a song fully. In the middle, I'm like, OK, I'm tired of this song.
我想——我得查看我的播放列表，因为我放了大约65首歌。因为我的问题是我从来没法完整放完一首歌。中间我心想，好吧，我对这首歌厌倦了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
But I do know some artists. I played some of his favorite artists, which are The Temptations, The Whispers. I played some of my mom's favorite artists, which were the Bee Gees-- which is hilarious.
但我确实知道一些歌手。我放了一些他最喜欢的歌手，比如The Temptations，The Whispers。我放了一些我妈妈最喜欢的歌手，比如Bee Gees——这太搞笑了。
And when I seen him, he looked different in a good way. Like, my dad never had a beard before. So I was like, wow, you have a beard. And he looked so thin. Not in a bad way-- like, you could tell he lost a lot of weight.
当我看到他时，他看起来不同了，是从好的方面。比如，我爸爸以前从来没留过胡子。所以我心想，哇，你有胡子了。他看起来太瘦了。不是那种坏的瘦——看得出他减了很多体重。
And I said, I'm like, wow, if Mom could have seen you now. It just felt like we just kind of pressed play. It's like-- all right, you know how you play a CD, and it just skips, and you're just in some random scene? I felt like I was just like in a random splash of happiness. It just didn't happen.
我说，我心想，哇，如果妈妈能看到你现在这样就好了。这感觉就像我们只是按下了一个播放键。就像——好吧，你知道当你放一张CD时，它会跳过，你就在某个随机场景里吗？我感觉就像是在一种随机的快乐浪潮中。这一切都没发生过。
Once I got him in that car, it felt like it didn't happen. I'm like, wow. Like, I literally have you in the car. And you don't-- I didn't expect you to look like this, but you look better. And then we started talking about food and just normal things we talked about. And I was like, wow, I feel like Winnie the Pooh and Christopher Robin. [LAUGHS]
当我把他接上车，感觉就像那没发生过一样。我心想，哇。我真的把你接在车里了。你没有——我没料到你会看起来这样，但你看起来更好。然后我们开始谈论食物和我们谈论过的正常事情。我心想，哇，我觉得自己是小熊维尼和克里斯多弗·罗宾。[笑]
How so?
怎么说？
It's-- OK. Every time, the end of the movie, they go to the special place where they just talk about random things, and it's called the Enchanted Forest. And it's kind of like that whole car ride was just conversations of things he missed, things that have been going on, random things that we'd talked about before, what we've been craving to eat. And it just is so amazing.
是——好吧。每次，电影结尾，他们去那个特殊的地方谈论随机事情，那叫“百亩森林”。整段车程就像那样，都是关于他错过的东西、正在发生的事情、我们之前谈论过的随机琐事、我们一直渴望吃的东西的对话。这太神奇了。
And I'm like, wow, I almost-- I'm so happy that I almost forgot the trauma that I just experienced.
我心想，哇，我差点——我太开心了，以至于我差点忘了我刚刚经历的创伤。
Mr. Granger's at home, but still in recovery. When I talked to him, he could walk up to 9 minutes at a time. He's hoping to make it around the block soon without a walker.
Granger先生现在在家，但仍在恢复中。当我与他交谈时，他一次可以步行9分钟。他希望很快不用助行器绕着街区走一圈。
Emanuele Berry.
Emanuele Berry。
Act Four, "Mr. Eastside." Some of the first COVID patients to arrive at Henry Ford were police and others who'd attended a community breakfast in early March called Police and Pancakes. And we were especially interested in the story of that breakfast and those patients because it illustrates the scale of loss outside the hospital walls, the scale of loss in the city of Detroit.
第四幕，“东区先生”。亨利福特医院最早接收的新冠病人中，有一些是警察以及其他参加了三月初一个名为“警察与煎饼”社区早餐会的人员。我们对那次早餐会和那些病人的故事特别感兴趣，因为这说明了医院墙外失落的规模，底特律城市失落的规模。
Aaron Foley is from the city. He used to work as the city's chief storyteller, a position in the mayor's office that focuses on Detroiters telling their own narratives. He has this story of the breakfast, and of one man in particular who ended up at Henry Ford.
Aaron Foley来自该市。他曾担任该市的首席叙事官，这是市长办公室的一个职位，侧重于底特律人讲述自己的故事。他有那个早餐会的故事，以及一位最终来到亨利福特的男人的故事。
I'm going to take you to the East Side of Detroit for a minute, which is hard for me to do as a West Sider, but I'll let it slide, because I want to tell you the story of someone who embodies everything the city's East Side is made of, Marlowe Stoudamire.
我带你们去底特律的东区呆一会儿，作为一个西区的人这对我来说很难，但我会放过它，因为我想告诉你们一个体现了底特律东区所造就的一切的人的故事：Marlowe Stoudamire。
The East Side is were some of the first Black Detroiters were able to legally purchase homes, and that includes some of Detroit's best attractions, like Belle Isle, which is something like our Central Park. But it also includes ZIP code 48205, which, in addition to diehard loyalists, has had one of the highest crime rates in the city.
东区是黑人底特律人能够合法购买房屋的地方，包括底特律的一些最好的景点，比如贝勒岛，这有点像我们的中央公园。但它也包括48205邮区，除了坚定的忠诚者外，该地区的犯罪率也是城市中最高的之一。
The policing in that ZIP code, and in the rest of the city, included so much excessive force that the Detroit Police Department, the DPD, was put under a consent decree for years. And ever since, police have been trying to establish a better relationship with the community. The Police and Pancakes Breakfast was part of that.
在该邮区及城市其他地方的警务工作，包含太多过度武力，导致底特律警察局（DPD）被置于同意令下多年。从那时起，警察一直在试图与社区建立更好的关系。“警察与煎饼”早餐会是其中的一部分。
The precinct there, the Ninth Precinct, held the breakfast to highlight the progress that they'd made and to try to get more voices in the conversation about police, like young people, pastors, and business owners. It was at Fisher Magnet Upper Academy-- a table in the entryway for name tags, and long buffet tables where heated trays of hash browns, eggs, and, of course, pancakes are waiting.
那里的警局，第九分局，举办了这次早餐会，以突出他们取得的进展，并试图让更多声音加入关于警察的对话，比如年轻人、牧师和店主。地点是在费舍尔磁铁上层学院——入口处有一张桌子用来贴姓名牌，长长的自助餐桌上摆着加热托盘，里面装着薯饼、鸡蛋，当然还有煎饼。
About 100 people were at the opening session-- police officers, of course, but also residents, representatives of the mayor's office, state legislators, and some high-achieving high school students, like senior Harley James. He's wearing a suit on a school day. His principal texted him the night before asking if he could come. He's a good public speaker, with a full ride to Michigan State this fall. When he arrived, the crowd was exactly what he expected it would be.
大约100人参加了开幕环节——当然是警察，但也包括居民、市长办公室的代表、州议员，以及一些学业有成的中学生，比如高中生Harley James。他在学校里穿着西装。校长前一天晚上给他发短信，问他能不能来。他是个很好的公众演讲者，今年秋天可以全额奖学金进入密歇根州立大学。当他到达时，人群正是他预期的样子。
A lot of old people.
很多老人家。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
It felt like one of them events that don't nobody go to. But like, I didn't expect no high schoolers to be there. It wasn't barely any high schoolers there. It wasn't something a teenager would go to just like-- if they were just like, oh, let's go to that. It was just, like, all grown people there.
感觉就像没人会去的那种活动。但我没指望会有高中生在那儿。那里几乎没有高中生。如果他们只是——哦，我们去那儿吧，那不是青少年会做的事情。那里全是成年人。
Letty Azar, who works in the Mayor's Office handling community affairs on the East Side, was speaking that day. When she arrived, she saw Harley and gave him a big hug, not surprised that he'd be out of the classroom for an event like this.
Letty Azar在市长办公室负责东区的社区事务，那天她发表了讲话。当她到达时，她看到了Harley并给了他一个大大的拥抱，并不惊讶他会为了这样的活动离开教室。
I mean, the kid can network like nobody's business. He's an incredible young man. So--
我是说，这孩子搞人际网络的能力无人能及。他是个不可思议的年轻人。所以——
She's looking around the crowd to see who's here, looking around at all the different police, worried that the message of the breakfast won't come across.
她在人群中环顾四周，看看谁在场，环顾着所有不同的警察，担心早餐会的信息无法传达出来。
And then I saw Marlowe, and that was a big reassurance that, in fact, it was going to be a good day and a great event.
然后我看到了Marlowe，这让我大大地放心，事实证明那将是一个美好的一天，一个伟大的活动。
Marlowe is a community staple in Detroit. He had been tapped to help organize this event and host one of the portions of the breakfast as well. Letty worked with him a lot last year, side-by-side in intense community meetings where he put people at ease and got their trust. But she hadn't seen him in a few months.
Marlowe是底特律社区的中流砥柱。他被选为帮助组织这次活动，并主持早餐会的部分环节。Letty去年和他共事很多，在激烈的社区会议上并肩工作，他让人们放松并赢得了他们的信任。但她已经几个月没见过他了。
But I remember him walking through the entry door, and he just-- he gave me the biggest hug and lifted me right off my feet. And we were both so excited to do this together that morning. And I was kind of reminded of that, the minute I saw his face-- that any concerns we had about how successful that day would be just went away once you saw Marlowe and got that hug.
但我记得他走过入口，他只是——他给了我一个最大的拥抱，把我都举离了地面。那天早上我们都非常兴奋能一起做这件事。一看到他的脸，我就被提醒了——我们对那天会多么成功的任何担忧，一旦看到Marlowe并得到那个拥抱，就都消失了。
One of the other people Marlowe ran into was my friend, Adam Hollier. We went to high school together. Now he's a state senator, representing part of the East Side. So he's always at events like the pancake breakfast. But today, he wasn't giving out any hugs.
Marlowe遇到的另一个人是我的朋友，Adam Hollier。我们一起上的高中。现在他是州参议员，代表东区的一部分。所以他总是出现在像煎饼早餐会这样的活动中。但今天，他没给任何人拥抱。
I was taking COVID-19 very seriously. People were, like, foot tapping or elbow bumping, but I wasn't. I was trying to keep my distance with folks, just because my mother had recently got through chemo, and I was operating under an abundance of caution throughout this process.
我非常认真地对待COVID-19。人们都在跺脚或碰肘，但我没有。我试图与人们保持距离，只是因为我的母亲最近刚做完化疗，我在整个过程中都非常谨慎。
And then he saw Marlowe, and he forgot all that.
然后他看到了Marlowe，他忘记了这一切。
Nobody has a quick interaction with Marlowe Stoudamire. I mean, that's a guy that makes you feel like you matter, right? A good friend of mine was teasing him-- like, Marlowe's that hustle guy who found his way to work in the system, not on the outside of it. He's just like, hey, I need five turkeys, or I need to get these kids from this practice to this practice. And then, all of a sudden, you need a referee. It's like, well, where are you going to get the referee? You just call Marlowe.
没人能与Marlowe Stoudamire进行短暂交流。我是说，那是一个让你感觉你很重要的人，对吧？我的一个好朋友在逗他——Marlowe就是那种在体制内找到工作方法，而不是在体制外的人。他就像是：嘿，我需要五只火鸡，或者我需要把这些孩子从这个练习带到那个练习。然后，突然间，你需要一个裁判。就像：嗯，去哪找裁判？你给Marlowe打电话就行。
Everybody has a story about Marlowe, and Marlowe seemed to know everybody who was trying to make life better for Black Detroit. He'd host these people on a makeshift talk show he did on Facebook Live.
每个人都有关于Marlowe的故事，Marlowe似乎认识每一个试图让黑人底特律生活变得更好的人。他会在Facebook Live上主持一个临时的脱口秀节目。
I want to talk to you about a special guest that I have today. She's killing it right now, in a major way. Brittany Rhodes-- yeah, that's her-- is the founder of Black Girl MATHgic, all right? It's "math" and "magic." Put them together--
我想跟你们谈谈我今天的一位特别嘉宾。她现在做得非常棒，非常出色。Brittany Rhodes——是的，就是她——是Black Girl MATHgic的创始人，好吗？是“数学”和“魔术”。把它们放在一起——
I first met Marlowe when we were both invited to speak at the Massachusetts Institute of Technology-- for a panel about Detroit, of course. I had just started working for the mayor's office as chief storyteller, and I was getting some backlash because the mayor is white, and I'm not.
我第一次见到Marlowe时，我们都被邀请去麻省理工学院演讲——当然是关于底特律的一个小组会议。我刚开始在市长办公室担任首席叙事官，我受到了一些反弹，因为市长是白人，而我不是。
I had a long career as a journalist, and the mayor hired me during an election year. People said I sold out. I heard rumors about me that I was just hired on to finesse the mayor's image. And because of that, I didn't know who in Detroit I could trust.
我曾有很长的记者生涯，市长在选举年雇佣了我。人们说我卖国。我听到关于我的谣言，说我只是被雇来美化市长的形象。因此，我不知道在底特律能信任谁。
That very first time I met him, Marlowe sensed something was wrong with me during that trip to Boston. So he got me to open up. He was disarming, and I shared with him some of the mixed emotions I was having about what people were saying about me back home.
第一次见到他时，Marlowe在波士顿的那次旅行中感觉到我出了问题。所以他让我敞开心扉。他很有感染力，我与他分享了一些关于人们在家乡议论我的复杂情绪。
He told me, and I quote, "That really pisses me the fuck off that people would say that about you. And if anybody has anything to say about it, we're going to deal with them." I never forgot that. Marlowe told me to "fuck 'em"-- his words. He told me that folks are rooting for me, folks are watching me, folks are wanting me to do well, and that he was excited for me and he was counting on me.
他告诉我，引用：“人们那样说你真的很他妈让我生气。如果任何人对此有任何意见，我们会解决他们的。”我永远不会忘记那次。Marlowe告诉我要“去他的”——他的原话。他告诉我大家都在为我加油，大家都在看着我，大家都在希望我做得好，他为我感到兴奋，并且指望我。
Just weeks after the breakfast, Marlowe Stoudamire would become the first person in Detroit publicly identified as dying from the virus.
就在早餐会几周后，Marlowe Stoudamire成为底特律第一个公开确认为死于该病毒的人。
Yo, yo, yo, good morning, Detroit. Good morning. This is Marlowe Stoudamire with another edition of Saturday Morning Coffee, at another location, as you will see and find out in a few minutes.
哟，哟，哟，早上好，底特律。早上好。我是Marlowe Stoudamire，这是Saturday Morning Coffee的另一期，在另一个地点，你们几分钟后就会看到并发现。
Here he is the day after the Police and Pancakes Breakfast, discussing the event on his makeshift talk show, which he hosted every Saturday on Facebook Live.
这是他在“警察与煎饼”早餐会后的第二天，在他的临时脱口秀节目上讨论这件事，他每周六在Facebook Live上主持这个节目。
I had the privilege of being invited by Justin Kimpson at the Ford Resource and Engagement Center-- shout out to Justin-- over on the East Side to facilitate a conversation between the community and the Detroit Police Department. And it was called Police and Pancakes. And the cool thing about it was is that they brought in the different police and different community stakeholders, and the whole conversation was how to create a better community experience with the Detroit Police Department.
我有幸受到东区福特资源和参与中心的Justin Kimpson的邀请——给Justin点个赞——去促进社区与底特律警察局之间的对话。它的名字叫“警察与煎饼”。很酷的事情是，他们带来了不同的警察和不同的社区利益相关者，整个对话都是关于如何与底特律警察局创造更好的社区体验。
On that video, he also talked about his health. This was before COVID really hit Detroit. It wasn't on most people's minds. And he chalked it up to his lifestyle-- hustling, grinding, always going hard, 24/7.
在那段视频中，他还谈到了他的健康状况。这是在新冠真正袭击底特律之前。大多数人还没想到它。他把它归结为他的生活方式——忙碌、打拼、总是全力以赴，24/7。
I ran into one of my frat brothers over the weekend, last weekend. And he said, man, I really like the stuff that you're doing, the moves you're making out here, and all these other different things. But one of the things that he talked about was-- he said, make sure you take care of yourself. He said, you need to find a way to have self-care.
周末，上周末，我碰到了我的一位兄弟。他说，伙计，我真的很喜欢你正在做的事情，你在这里所做的动作，以及所有这些其他不同的事情。但他谈到的其中一件事是——他说，确保照顾好你自己。他说，你需要找到一种方法进行自我保健。
And what's interesting is that this week was a week where I felt bad. I had a few health challenges. I had a procedure done this week. And I realized that I hadn't been taking care of myself. So I need to make some adjustments--
有趣的是，这周是我感觉很糟糕的一周。我有一些健康挑战。我这周做了一个手术。我意识到我没照顾好自己。所以我需要做一些调整——
No one knows exactly how COVID started spreading through Detroit, but law enforcement was hit hard in the beginning, and dozens of officers were at Police and Pancakes. At its height, more than 500 DPD employees were quarantined to contain the spread-- about 1/5 of the force.
没人确切知道新冠是如何开始在底特律蔓延的，但在开始时执法部门受到重创，几十名警官参加了“警察与煎饼”。最严重的时候，超过500名DPD员工被隔离以控制传播——大约是警力的五分之一。
As COVID spread through Michigan, I remember looking at what people in Detroit were sharing on Facebook. There are a lot of requests for prayer. But there are a lot of jokes, too-- some about how Vernors, the popular ginger ale, was all Detroiters needed to beat this deadly virus.
随着新冠蔓延到密歇根州，我记得看着人们在Facebook上分享的内容。有很多祈祷请求。但也有很多笑话——关于流行的姜汁汽水Vernors是底特律人打败这种致命病毒所需的全部。
After Police and Pancakes, the Detroit Health Department began letting attendees know that they may have been exposed to the virus. People started wondering if they were carriers and who they might be passing it on to. Harley had left Police and Pancakes and went back to school. Letty left for another community event in District 4. Adam went to mingle with some pretty big names.
“警察与煎饼”之后，底特律卫生局开始让参加者知道他们可能接触过病毒。人们开始怀疑自己是否是携带者，以及他们可能传给了谁。Harley离开早餐会回到学校。Letty去参加了第四区的另一个社区活动。Adam去和一些大人物接触。
As soon as I left the breakfast, I went over to the Joe Biden office opening, the Joe Biden for President piece. And so I was there with the LG--
早餐会一结束，我就去了Joe Biden办公室揭幕仪式，Joe Biden竞选总统的部分。所以我和副州长在那里——
The lieutenant governor.
副州长。
--Representatives Yancey and Tate, and former governor Blanchard as we kicked off the office. And I drove up to Cornell and then came back. And that Monday night, we had the big Joe Biden rally at Renaissance. And that was the last big event that I had gone to.
——Yancey和Tate代表，以及前州长Blanchard，我们在启动办公室。我开车去康奈尔然后回来。那个周一晚上，我们在Renaissance举行了Joe Biden的大型集会。那是我参加过的最后一个大型活动。
But at that same moment, I bump into Cory Booker, and Kamala Harris, and a host of Congressional members, and I'm with the governor. When I got the call, maybe a week later, that Marlowe had tested positive, it was like, man, god, I just hope I didn't give somebody COVID-19. And when you look back at those moments, it was all very scary, because you're like, well, when, how, if? Do I have it?
但在同一时刻，我撞见了Cory Booker和Kamala Harris，还有一大批国会议员，我和州长在一起。大约一周后当我接到电话得知Marlowe检测呈阳性时，心想：伙计，天哪，我只希望我没有给某人新冠。当你回顾那些时刻时，一切都很可怕，因为你会心想：好吧，什么时候，怎么，如果？我有它吗？
He didn't get sick.
他没生病。
Marlowe once worked at Henry Ford as community and diversity manager, and later, director of international business strategy. When he got there in March, he was one of the first patients treated for COVID-19 in Pod Four in the ICU. His time there was short. He died on March 24. Someone from work, a mutual friend, called Letty with the news.
Marlowe曾作为社区和多元化经理在亨利福特工作，后来担任国际商业战略总监。三月份当他到达那里时，他是ICU四号病区治疗的第一批新冠病人之一。他待在那的时间很短。他于3月24日去世。一个同事，共同的朋友，打电话给Letty告知消息。
Was he the first person you knew that had passed from it, or--
他是你认识的第一个因为这个去世的人，还是——
He was. But interestingly, three hours later, I got a call on a DPD friend who had passed away. That's Jonathan Parnell, who was one of our DPD captains. And I've known his family for some time. So he was a great guy, very well-respected police officer and member of the community.
他是。但有趣的是，三小时后，我接到一个DPD朋友去世的电话。那是Jonathan Parnell，他是我们的DPD队长之一。我认识他的家人一段时间了。所以他是个很棒的人，非常受人尊敬的警官和社区成员。
So it was Marlowe and Recon that day, and then the next day two, more. Then, the next day, three more. And that week of March that Marlowe passed away was-- I hope to never have to live anything like that again.
所以那天是Marlowe和Recon，然后第二天两个，更多。然后，第二天，三个更多。Marlowe去世的那三月的一周是——我希望永远不要再经历那样的生活了。
But it was just unbelievable, the number of calls, and texts, and people you knew that you worked with, you prayed with, you ate with, you grew up with, that you would see at community meetings, that you realize you're just never going to see again. We lost so many valuable souls in this city. And to come out of this pandemic-- they'd be the first people you'd turn to to say, all right, how do we get everybody-- how do we help rebuild some momentum? And they're not there.
但你认识的，你共事过、祈祷过、一起吃过饭、一起长大、在社区会议上会见到的电话、短信和人们的数量简直让人难以置信，你意识到你再也不会见到他们了。我们在这座城市失去了这么多宝贵的灵魂。而走出这场大流行——他们将是你们最先求助的人，说：好吧，我们如何让每个人——我们如何帮助重建动力？而他们不在了。
Over the next few hours on that day, tributes started to pour in across social media about Marlowe, about how Detroit lost a giant, a champion, whatever your preferred term may be, and there was now a void that couldn't be filled. Who do you call now when you need advice or when you need mentorship? Who calls you when you need to be checked on? Who among us did he leave, and what would he be doing now in this moment when racial inequities have been laid bare, not just by the virus, but also by the killing of George Floyd?
在随后的几个小时里，社交媒体上开始涌现对Marlowe的致敬，关于底特律失去了一个巨人，一个冠军，无论你喜欢什么术语，现在有一个无法填补的空白。当你需要建议或需要导师时你现在该给谁打电话？当你需要被关注时谁会给你打电话？他留下了我们中的谁，在种族不平等不仅被病毒而且被George Floyd的杀害暴露出来的这一刻，他会做什么？
In Detroit, another name you hear at the demonstrations these days is Aiyana Stanley-Jones. She was a seven-year-old girl from the East Side who was killed in a police raid while she slept on a couch back in 2010. Adam Hollier-- my friend, the state rep-- says Marlowe would be jumping in right now to help realize the goals of Black Lives Matter, wherever the biggest need is.
在底特律，你这些天在游行中听到的另一个名字是Aiyana Stanley-Jones。她是从东区来的一个七岁小女孩，2010年在一场警察突袭中在沙发上睡觉时被杀。我的朋友，州代表Adam Hollier说，Marlowe现在会跳出来帮助实现Black Lives Matter的目标，无论需求最大的地方在哪里。
Oh, Marlowe? I mean, Marlowe is the type of person who would have been in the forefront. But he'd also have been someone that white people would have been reaching out to, right? So I have gotten a number of calls and texts from my well-intentioned, caring white friends who were like, hey, just checking in on you. Thinking about you.
哦，Marlowe？我是说，Marlowe是那种会站在最前线的人。但他也会是白人会伸出援手的人，对吧？所以我接到了许多我的心地善良、有爱心的白人朋友的电话和短信，他们说：嘿，只是关心你。想到你了。
Marlowe would have been the king of getting those kind of things, right? There would have been a host of people reaching out to him. And they'd say, well, how can I be helping?
Marlowe会是那种得到这些东西的国王，对吧？会有许多人向他伸出援手。他们会说：嗯，我能怎么帮忙？
He was like, well, you can do these three things, right? He'd say, I've got this organization that is doing this work. You can donate. Your business could hire more Black people. You can do these things.
他会说：好吧，你可以做这三件事，对吧？他会说：我有这个组织在做这项工作。你可以捐款。你的企业可以雇佣更多黑人。你可以做这些事情。
And I think people are now willing to say that Black Lives Matter. What they aren't willing to say is how much they value them, right? How much do they matter? He would have been uniquely situated to have those conversations with people.
我认为人们现在愿意说黑人的命也是命。他们不愿意说的是他们有多重视他们，对吧？他们有多重要？他会处于独特的位置与人们进行这些对话。
James Feagin IV is another one of those connectors in Detroit who I know knows everybody. Anytime I see him out, he's in a blazer and a button-up shirt. But now--
James Feagin IV是底特律另一位那些连接者，我知道他认识每个人。每次我在外面见到他，他都穿着西装外套和衬衫。但现在——
Do I have to be in "sound bite, I'm on the air" mode? Or can I just talk?
我一定要处于“声音比特，我在广播中”模式吗？还是我可以随便聊聊？
Just talk.
随便聊。
All right. Because yeah, I'm in gym shorts on my patio right now. I'm not on right now.
好吧。因为是的，我现在穿着健身短裤在露台上。我现在没在广播。
That's fine.
没关系。
Both James and Marlowe are around 40. They both grew up on the East Side during that chaotic time in Detroit when crack started to ravage the city. They both built their careers in Detroit, dedicated to Detroit.
James和Marlowe都40岁左右。他们都在底特律混乱时期在东区长大，当时可卡因开始蹂躏这座城市。他们都在底特律建立了事业，致力于底特律。
Where is Marlowe missing right now?
Marlowe现在缺席在哪里？
[EXHALES] You know, this was a question I started thinking about the other day. And it was tough, because I'm still mourning. And a lot of us are. But the sad irony that Marlowe's last act was at a Police and Pancakes breakfast on the Far East Side, trying to foster positive-- I'm sorry. [SOBS] Positive relations with young black males and the police. That's what's missing right now, you know? [SOBS]
[呼气] 你知道，这是我前几天开始思考的一个问题。这很难，因为我还在哀悼。我们中的许多人也是。但悲伤的讽刺是Marlowe的最后一次行动是在东区Far East Side的警察与煎饼早餐会上，试图促进积极——对不起。[抽泣] 与年轻黑人男性和警察之间的积极关系。那就是现在缺失的，你知道吗？[抽泣]
There's a lot of us who may have had negative experiences with police, but we also got police in our family, friends. If we could create more forums like that, then it would help everybody. Because our goal is that everybody, number one, stays alive, and number two, has a chance to contribute to a better Detroit and a better Black community. And I can just see him right now being that person that would be as angry as we all are about what happened to George Floyd, but also have some real relationships to point to and lean on.
我们中有很多人可能与警察有过负面经历，但我们的家人、朋友中也有警察。如果我们能创造更多那样的论坛，那对每个人都有帮助。因为我们的目标是，第一，每个人保持活着，第二，有机会为更美好的底特律和更美好的黑人社区做出贡献。我现在能看到他就是那种会对George Floyd发生的事情像我们所有人一样愤怒，但也会有一些真实的关系可以依靠的人。
When I talked to Marlowe's wife, Valencia, she didn't want to discuss the final days of her husband's life and says their two children are still adjusting to life without their dad. But she told me this story about an overseas trip they took just this past fall.
当我与Marlowe的妻子Valencia交谈时，她不想讨论丈夫生命的最后几天，并说他们的两个孩子仍在适应没有父亲的生活。但她告诉我这个关于他们去年秋天去海外旅行的故事。
We went to Rome in October. And literally, we saw the Colosseum. And he was, like, tearing up. And I'm like, oh, babe, you know, what's wrong? And he's like, you just don't understand. I'm not supposed to be here. This was what I saw in textbooks. This was not real.
我们十月去了罗马。字面上，我们看到了斗兽场。他当时，像是，泪流满面。我心想：哦，宝贝，你知道，怎么了？他说：你只是不明白。我不应该在这儿。这是我在教科书中看到的。这不是真的。
And here's what had me to believe that it wasn't. (VOICE BREAKING) It wasn't real for me as a Black male. It wouldn't be my reality to see it. And it was overwhelming to him. I'm so glad we got to have that experience.
这就是让我相信它不是真的原因。（声音颤抖）这对我作为一个黑人男性来说不是真的。看到它不会是我的现实。这对他来说太震撼了。我很高兴我们能有那个经历。
But he just-- it was very important for him that he beat the odds. And it was important to him that not only did he beat them, but all of the young men that looked like him behind him had an opportunity to do the same. And I think that was the most important thing to him.
但他只是——他打败了困难对他来说非常重要。对他来说重要的是，他不仅打败了他们，而且所有在他身后看起来像他的年轻人都有机会做同样的事情。我认为那是对他来说最重要的事情。
Last year, Marlowe did this thing for 50 days straight where, each day, he'd write a Facebook post about two Black people in Detroit he saw potential in, which he later turned into a website called Roster Detroit. This came after a Chamber of Commerce official said that Amazon didn't choose Detroit for its new headquarters partly because the city didn't have enough talent. Marlowe's response was this list to say, here's what you missed out on.
去年，Marlowe连续50天做了一件事，每天他都会写一篇关于他在底特律看到的两个有潜力的黑人的Facebook帖子，后来他将其变成了一个叫Roster Detroit的网站。这是在商会官员说亚马逊没有选择底特律作为其新总部部分是因为该市没有足够的人才之后发生的。Marlowe的回应就是这个名单，说是：这就是你们错过的东西。
Right now, the list of people we've lost to COVID is too long. So, too, is the list of people we've lost to police brutality. These lists are about Black death. But at this moment, I like to think about Roster Detroit, Marlowe's list of Black talent-- a list that's about Black people, living.
现在，我们因新冠失去的人的名单太长了。同样，我们因警察暴行失去的人的名单也是如此。这些名单是关于黑人死亡。但在这一刻，我喜欢想的是Roster Detroit，Marlowe的黑人人才名单——一个关于黑人生活的名单。
Aaron Foley. He's about to become the head of the Black Media Initiative at the Newmark Graduate School of Journalism at the City University of New York.
Aaron Foley。他即将成为纽约城市大学Newmark新闻研究生院黑人媒体计划的负责人。
I'm looking at this sign in the window. I don't know if y'all can see it. It says, "Nothing stops Detroit." Nothing stops the people of Detroit, is what I would say. And the point that I'm making is, y'all, look-- if not us, then who? You got to make a decision about who you're going to be, right? And the city has to make a decision about what it's going to be and who it's going to be.
我看着窗户上的这个标志。我不知道你们是否能看到它。上面写着：“没什么能阻止底特律。”没什么能阻止底特律的人民，这就是我会说的。我要强调的是，你们看——如果不是我们，那会是谁？你必须决定你想成为谁，对吧？这个城市必须决定它想成为什么，以及它想成为谁。
And I will tell you right now, it's tough. But the last time I checked, this was the D. And so I will just say, stay motivated, stay connected, and help people. Help people, help people, help people. I'll help you. Hit me up. All right, D. Holla.
我现在就告诉你们，这很难。但我上次检查时，这是D城。所以我只会说，保持动力，保持联系，并帮助人们。帮助人们，帮助人们，帮助人们。我会帮助你们。联系我。好吧，D城。喊出来。
Well, our program was produced today by Miki Meek and Emanuele Barry. The people who put together our show today includes Bim Adewunmi, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Hilary Elkins, Noor Gill, Damien Graef, Michelle Harris, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, and Katharine Mae Mondo, Lisa Pollock, Nadia Reiman, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney. Our managing editors are Diane Wheeler and Sarah Abdurrahman. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum.
嗯，我们的节目今天由Miki Meek和Emanuele Barry制作。今天制作我们节目的人包括Bim Adewunmi、Susan Burton、Ben Calhoun、Dana Chivvis、Sean Cole、Aviva DeKornfeld、Hilary Elkins、Noor Gill、Damien Graef、Michelle Harris、Lina Misitzis、Stowe Nelson以及Katharine Mae Mondo、Lisa Pollock、Nadia Reiman、Brian Reed、Robyn Semien、Christopher Swetala和Matt Tierney。我们的管理编辑是Diane Wheeler和Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的执行编辑是David Kestenbaum。
Special thanks today to Michael Eichenhorn, Sara Hegab, Jackie Pflaum, Kristen Chasteen, Kim North Shine, Patrick Bradley, Brittni Brown, Lamont Jones, Tatiana Grant, Melinda Madrigal, Imani Mixon, John Raniszewski, Jeffrey Rowe, Sonia Russell, Marcus Thirkill, Angela Wicks, Sarah Alvarez, Todd Bettison, Pamela Chen, Toni Davis, Gillian Grafton, Emily Ioco, Scott Kaatz, Toson Knight, Ricardo Marble, Carrie Morgan, Betty Morris, Varidhi Nauriyal, John Roach, Driadonna Rowland, Steve Poloni, Stacey Prantera, Zachary Smith, Jeff Wattrick, and Stateline, a journalism project funded by the Pew Charitable Trusts.
今天特别感谢Michael Eichenhorn、Sara Hegab、Jackie Pflaum、Kristen Chasteen、Kim North Shine、Patrick Bradley、Brittni Brown、Lamont Jones、Tatiana Grant、Melinda Madrigal、Imani Mixon、John Raniszewski、Jeffrey Rowe、Sonia Russell、Marcus Thirkill、Angela Wicks、Sarah Alvarez、Todd Bettison、Pamela Chen、Toni Davis、Gillian Grafton、Emily Ioco、Scott Kaatz、Toson Knight、Ricardo Marble、Carrie Morgan、Betty Morris、Varidhi Nauriyal、John Roach、Driadonna Rowland、Steve Poloni、Stacey Prantera、Zachary Smith、Jeff Wattrick以及Stateline，一个由Pew慈善信托基金资助的新闻项目。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he actually met Donald Trump once. This was years ago. Kind of a weird story.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX分发到公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。你知道，他实际上见过唐纳德·特朗普一次。那是几年前的事了。是个有点奇怪的故事。
He literally asked me, did I need any money?
他竟然问我：你需要钱吗？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。